get your nostalgia talk out of here
pokemon wasn't that great but i'm pretty
sure you gave digimon the nade
okay yes yes digimon is better than
pokemon i will
fight you on this the digimon kid is
like the og neighbors kid you know what
i mean yeah
what's up crackheads welcome back to
another episode of the trash taste
podcast i'm your host joey and i'm with
the other
crackheads i like how you like started
with alliteration at the start of this
podcast and now it's just like that you
gave up with the alliteration
well that'd be
notorious for having a welcome sense
they understand satire i never do
monetize for no reason at all
never happened in the history of youtube
no of course not any youtuber
it's not like it happened on the last
chris episode or anything you know
it's fine to be fair i think that was
just the uh copious amounts of alcohol
we consumed on that episode
i think that was the demonetization that
forced us into just being a mess which
i'm fine with but you know just
just a mess but welcome to this episode
welcome to this episode of trash taste
so hopefully this one's not going to get
demonetized because we're going to be
talking about
anime whoa wait we're going to be
talking about
what do you remember when uh he's
talking about anime do you remember when
this podcast was an anime podcast
i'm not gonna bring that back i'm glad
that i stopped this from becoming an
anime podcast
my influence and then and then
me and god were like no we must bring
her back
like i'm feeling nostalgic now cause i
get to talk about anime again on this
podcast my [ __ ] god
i mean we barely talk about anime on our
own
i like it that way i like being an anime
fan
that's what i like yeah we're all anime
fans yeah but uh today
uh we're gonna we're gonna talk about it
we're gonna talk about some anime more
specifically
we are going to be doing what we do best
which is roasting our
trash tastes see anime okay as like
anime youtubers and connor
like you know don't do me like that all
right
one of the most annoying questions we
get asked i'm sure is
what is your favorite anime like
you get asked this at every panel at
every fan meetup you've ever gone to
and i swear to god i don't know about
you but i have a different answer every
time
i i've loaded a default answer so i
don't have to think and that will like
satisfy
but as anime youtubers we know we are
normally the ones judging other people's
tastes but
now we are putting our own taste on the
line
and we are judging each other's tastes
and letting you all
judge our tastes along with us because
like
normally we don't promote our my anime
list or
we will get into what we're doing but
basically we are going to be showing
each other's my anime list
and then afterwards we are going to be
sh if you guys remember
there was this trend in the anime
community before called three by threes
where you basically pick nine anime in a
three by three grid
that you show to your fellow brethren
and that
basically encapsulates kind of your
taste of anime it's basically just like
a pinterest collage
[ __ ] tumbler girls in this case yeah
right
by like guys or pinterest or something
like that i think it was started by
4chan actually wasn't it
yeah of all things 4chan creates
they made this yeah so uh in in
trash taste spirit we're going to bring
back trash box skin right here if you
guys remember from our
episodes that was that was half a year
was that was over half a year
that was like six seven months ago jesus
but uh we're gonna bring it back and uh
to make it fair we're gonna pull out uh
oh wait what's this doing oh yeah that
was me i did i did
yeah this is my hidden anime list so i
actually have one from when i was a
teenager right that i never made public
and people would always ask me for my
anime list so i actually made a my anime
list
under sea dog va and just put like boca
no pico as like a 10.
and then every now and then i get a
comment on it being like i hate uconn
yeah so hi
yeah my my username as well i mean i've
done a video on it already so people
know but it's like my username is not
even the anime man
it was a blast for me it was the
username i used before i was the anime
man
right the zinger what are you a big bang
finger
okay so first thing i gotta ask is how
when was the last time you remember
updating this because like
like i'm going to say this now we're all
picking up our mouse i haven't updated
my mail in
years okay i'll give you i'll give you
an idea all right i'm looking at my
watching
list right now and uh boku no hero
academia second season is on here yeah
you've got you've got a
91 days here and that was like what
three or four years ago no i've already
finished that one though yeah but that's
like
how long good would that come out 91
days two years no [ __ ] yeah
when did season two of my hero come out
like two two years ago
it was two years ago no it wasn't true
it was like
[ __ ] three guys realized they're
boomers
four years ago three four years ago so
it's been that long since i've updated
yeah all right okay
so wait wait are you telling me you've
watched my hero academia season one
i finished season one yeah how come
you've like never talked about this
before because it was like the most six
out of ten show i've ever watched
like but you'd normally milk that for
all it's worth being like yo it's mid
bros i'm triggering all the little
weaves i mean
like i could but also it's like i don't
know
if to me like calling mikey or academia
mid
is just as much of a popular opinion as
saying that it's a 10 out of 10.
okay okay the the first thing that pops
out something on
it's mid but you gave it a seven out of
ten yeah it's exactly it's all right
it was how it was seven minutes it was
good but it wasn't like
the second coming of jesus that people
born
[Music]
the first thing that pops out to me here
right the first thing that pops out to
me here
as like i this is how i know joey's my
[ __ ] brethren here right
because as we all know my i started
as the anime zone right and my very
first
anime zone review right was bleach yeah
yeah yeah which i
gave a seven and i can see
that mr joey the anime man also came
please a seven out of ten
i mean despite the fact how much we've
[ __ ] on bleach
in our like a professional career look
look look
when i when i [ __ ] on bleach right i
mean granted i've never really like
publicly [ __ ] on bleach all that much
right like i didn't make like a [ __ ]
anime
review on bleacher but look the only
thing it's
three points off for the isen arc and
then
everything else was perfect you know
what i mean but like that's like
i mean i wouldn't i mean i would argue
everything after so soul society i mean
you you can like you can like the uh you
know the aaron carr arc
yeah yeah yeah whatever of course the
wicked window arc was fine as well yeah
yeah i mean it was it was fine but we've
never watched all red bleach really
no no you don't you don't need to yeah
you're not missing
and if you do just read or watch up to
soul society which is the first star
which is what i've heard you can't just
stop if you're like really you kind of
have to
yeah but you can't just though you want
to see no you see it go down no you
can't you can i mean i mean it
it depends like because bleach didn't go
out with a bang it's just i know yeah it
just like kind of
fizzled out well i've watched all like
reviews of bleach for some reason i've
watched like every eyepatch world video
on it and i'm like yeah
cool this sounds sounds good look don't
get me wrong it was
back in the day when it was serializing
it was a super solid shown in manga
yeah and like you know as much as i like
to think that i'm like oh you know i
like
all the underground like weird you know
non-mainstream [ __ ] yeah
i love my shonen and bleach was one of
them like i saw society
honestly to this day i think bleach is
one of
just the coolest anime to come out like
definitely i like
out of the big three which is like one
piece naruto and
bleach bleach was just like that [ __ ]
cool kid you know what i mean
it always seemed like the edgiest one it
was it was definitely the edgiest
yeah yeah yeah i mean have you seen what
kubota tito looks like he looks like i
mean i used to always see the
amvs it's like lincoln park with yeah
yeah i mean that that was pretty much
blue yeah
that was bleach yeah but it was like it
went better with like bleach because
they had like half skulls and [ __ ] i
don't know
what was going on was [ __ ] sick dude
like the powers were sick
it was just it was just the sword powers
were sick then like
i want to see some more bad guys guys
say what you want about kubo but like
he he has a good fashion sense oh yeah
the way he dressed the characters they
were they just always looked cool
yeah really the drip was clean
that's the perfect way to decide two
characters the drip was clean
like say what you want about bleach they
had those characters
i would go as far as to say that bleach
might be maybe not the first but
definitely one of the biggest
shows that kind of gave like i don't
know i don't know maybe
streetwear and animes like
collaborations i would argue maybe came
from bleach
yeah because a lot of the characters
especially in like the title um
panels that he wrote during the manga
like he gave them such cool [ __ ]
looking street yeah that
honestly you can see people wearing like
people want to see this like
drip goku exists yeah exactly bleach is
the reason why drip goku exists
is this a meme
[ __ ] i don't know who made it yeah
i'll show you but like it's it's this
[ __ ] meme of like goku like in the
[ __ ] like b-boy stance
wearing this [ __ ] drip it's like a
big meme right now
i don't know why this is a meme i i i
try to explain to some people and i'm
like but why is it a meme i'm like i
don't know i don't know but it's a meme
but the group is clean what what is
going back to dragon ball fans what is
dragon ball memes man
did this start on twitter i don't know
all right all right we're saying just
like drip goku strip coke
and then vegeta wearing like the supreme
like sweater as well just being like
it's clean goku got drip apparently
and there would be no drip goku without
drip bleaching if it wasn't for bleach
there'd be no
i feel like every kind of dragon ball
meme under the sun has just been like
every cancerous meme in like literally
cancerous memes yeah in terms of the
dragon ball
um community like you're lost for words
you're like
i'm surprised you've never seen it it's
all over twitter so you rated the
bleach the same as my hero season one
would you still stand by that
yeah i would because like look again as
much as i don't think
my hero is like the second coming of
christ season one was solid
as [ __ ] like i enjoyed it i i would i
would say
for me my hero it goes season two
than season one than season three right
right we haven't had season four yet
have we
i don't even know wait no no no no no we
haven't i don't think so i wouldn't no
we have no
i don't [ __ ] this too no no we haven't
no we haven't yeah
coming out merlin have we had a am i
here academia season four
it's called it's coming okay season
four's coming so
so the next one's announced but i i saw
on twitter everyone's like the next arc
is boring
and i was like great so just another
year of just mediocre [ __ ]
yeah even the biggest even the biggest
shonen right now is just like yeah
whatever
no i mean like the thing is with my hero
is that i started off really really
liking it
and to me to me like out of all the
modern shonen it had the potential to be
the greatest right like like he had the
potential to reach like a higher ceiling
than say
something like say black clover or demon
slayer or something like that
but it seems like the setup is there and
the potential is there but there just
hasn't been that moment for me to really
make me love this and the it seems like
the more
the more i watch just the less and less
invest i guess in there well that's how
i kind of felt watching season one like
you know the first half of season one to
me was like okay
i like this premise like superheroes
quirks okay cool yeah i can see why
people are into this and it's good [ __ ]
like
action scenes were pretty [ __ ] sold
characters pretty [ __ ] solid
but then the further along i got i was
just like yeah all right
all right yeah it's just it's just a
showing it's it's just good
it's just it's just good it's it's it's
like i i struggle
to find words just to describe how i
feel towards it because i'm just like
at the beginning i'm just like yeah i've
really liked this i'm really hyped for
this and the more i watch them i'm just
like
yeah it's good yeah there's not really
much to say about it that's all it is
it's just good good it's good it's
adequate it's like going to a cousin's
birthday party
it's just like yeah i'll go i'll go but
like you know i'm not that thrilled
about it yeah but i'll turn up yeah you
know
i'd be supportive how was your cousin's
birthday it was it was good yeah it was
[ __ ] good
yeah yeah that's how i feel that's how
the show is that's it yeah exactly
but that's the thing like people make it
out to be because i'm not you know
praising the [ __ ] out of it publicly
people immediately think oh joey hates
my hair academia i don't hate my
academia i just think it's fine i just
you know i just
like yeah i just cry every time deku
talks man that's
kind of i'm not a fan of deco i'm sorry
yeah i'm not a fan of deku either
um i don't understand why people love
bakugo so much i feel like is there
something like gone wrong in the
childhood of
girls who are like really into him to me
it's like he's just kind of an [ __ ] i
understand i understand why people love
total orgy like that is that is like set
up to be like
yeah fan favorite yeah yeah yeah why
bakugou is people's favorites i don't
understand
it's i it's like the worst kid in school
everyone's like i love this kid
it's like it's like it's like people
like we're talking about bleach it's
like back in bleach days when people
said that renji was their favorite i'm
like
what he's just an angry kid like no he's
a nice guy secretly and i'm like have
you ever met someone who's an [ __ ] in
real life
what's weird to me right it's like you
know the same kind of twitter accounts
and the same kind of fan base i see like
defending barca and having
him as their favorite character is like
the same kind of
accounts that i see [ __ ] trying to
cancel people for like
10 year old tweets or something like
that and i'm like here
they're trying to cancel people for that
here they are being like oh i mean
bucko like was a bully back in back in
like middle school whatever
but he's like turned around now he's a
good
it's a lot easier to get behind a
fictional character's turnaround story
yeah exactly right like there's people
defending vegeta and he's talking
he [ __ ] tried to blow up the planet
two weeks ago man jesus [ __ ] christ
it's all right he's he's a good guy now
but speaking of vegeta you you gave
dragon ball
and dragon ball z both a nine out of ten
yeah i thought dragon ball was [ __ ]
no that's good oh i know you gotta
this puts into perspective how long ago
was that i probably put that in
like how many [ __ ] rhyme on movies
you gave [ __ ] a doraemon movie a
masterpiece you give that a 10 and you
gonna give the
wait which one which star on one movie
they're so good there are many
16 you gave a 10. what is special about
16. okay that was like the schindler's
list of darim
that was the third doramon movie uh i
think it's 16.
no that the remake is 16. what the [ __ ]
yeah the the original is the third one
which i couldn't find
which it doesn't exist on my anime list
for some reason all right okay but i
gave that a 10 purely because i
watched that movie that that was one of
the first rhyme on movies i ever watched
and
i mean if you guys don't know me right
now right yeah i'm a bad guy now
yeah it's it's good like honestly like
sweat like
even now i could probably rewatch that
movie and still find it enjoyable
yeah i don't know durian diamond holds a
special place in my heart as you can
tell from the amount of [ __ ] door i'm
on movies
yeah yeah i'm just like i didn't even
know there were this many dare i want me
to do they're still making dorado i'm
i'm surprised someone else has been
watching doraemon
like further along than when they were a
kid watching on tv because that's the
only
exposure i've ever had to derive yeah
right i probably would never go out my
way yeah too much a [ __ ]
one i completely understand if you did
not grow up with doraemon
i do not blame you for not watching a
single diamond movie or episode because
that shit's hard to get into as an adult
yeah but if you're if you grew up with
it like i did then you could easily go
back and i know man to me it's kind of
like
yeah as a growing up growing up i would
just like watch the [ __ ] teletubbies
movie yeah right
like
like talk to like a niece or something
and then you're like oh show me what you
watch and you watch it you're like what
the [ __ ] is happening
this is [ __ ] it's just wild what is this
that's probably what my parents thought
when i what the [ __ ] is this blue thing
i i noticed you gave full metal
alchemist and full metal alchemist
brotherhood both
are seven yeah why because it's like my
hero
it was no it wasn't just being a
brotherhood is not it's like at least an
eight or a nine it wasn't except
i mean i can't look acceptable yeah it
was except hold on hold on
hold on let me let me let me act uh
let me act angry okay wait you gave full
metal alchemist a seven
how dare you joey how dare you i am so
[ __ ] offended right now it is the
audacity of this [ __ ] man
the audacity to the new viewers gone has
never won
that scene with nina and the dog
mike did did you not get the feels
i'm not trying to say like you need to
give it like a 10. i'm just saying
i think it's like minimum okay okay
here's the thing with that one i still
stand by that to this day
because like a lot of people it was not
the first anime i watched
i watched that right way after a kid
yeah me too right right yeah but it was
probably one of the first ones you
watched right
for the first 20. yeah exactly what does
that count this might have been in like
the first 200 for me
but i don't know i feel like out of all
the anime i've watched definitely the
best story here's the thing
my my experience with fullmetal
alchemist is basically
gone's next step which is because i hear
about it so much
i watched it out of obligation
god hasn't got to the stage i haven't
got to that stage
every time someone asks me a day gets
added on exactly i'm pretty sure
like and i was like and i was like that
as well and i'm just like you know what
i got time i'll [ __ ] watch it just
because i hear them
in the same like sitting or like how did
you know i watched so i watched
so people were like okay you don't have
to watch the first four minutes just
watch brotherhood right you hear that
all the [ __ ] time but i'm like no no
i want to see
why people are saying that right so i
watched the original
and i was like okay this was adequate so
brotherhood must be a lot better like a
lot lot better
that's what i heard yeah i think that i
was like yeah it's better but
like essentially this serves a point
higher better that's essentially no
it's not okay the first full metal
alchemist is like a low seven
and brotherhood is like a high seven
call it is
that's all it is to me also i'm
critiquing your scores here knowing that
you know some of these anime i've also
scored myself but i have no idea what i
said
because this is my list was down in 2014
yeah holy [ __ ]
seven years ago yeah yeah i see you've
given naruto a six compared to bleach so
would you say that you preferred bleach
over narrative absolutely
i prefer narrative really i have never
dropped a show
more times than i have narrator like
naruto has been one of those shows
where it's like i've i've watched it
i've read it and watched it like
close to the end yeah but along that way
there were so many points throughout
naruto where i'm just like
uh maybe it's not worth it you didn't
get that with bleach at all no i did get
that bit of bleach
once during the eisenhower that's it
yeah
i mean bleach for me was just like a
constant downhill naruto just kind of
went up and down
and i i like i think back to i think
back sometimes when i think is now was
naruto a good
show would it would it hold up to this
day and i still think some of the best
parts of naruto
are still like a [ __ ] amazing yeah
no again and that's and that's why i
probably gave it a six right because
like
i completely understand why it is one of
the most
beloved anime out there today right and
so like i saw parts of that but again
this was i didn't grow up with naruto
like a lot of people did like this was
again another show that this is just
another show
this is just another show right right
right yeah so
again i'm not saying that naruto is bad
i just like to point that out it's not
bad
but it's not a 10 out of 10 for me okay
i'm trying to see what else i feel like
i'm getting interrogated you know this
this is an interesting
interrogation this is like weeb
interrogation this is like true crime
weeb edition you know
so yes notice his hand movement his
hands are off the table saying that he
is quite nervous
so like we're not we're not like okay so
what is the lowest one that you've rated
on here i'm trying to see probably a one
i'm trying to see oh it's i think it's
pupa oh yeah pupa
i i get people one i think i get bulk
and a pico one yeah one of the the
biggest thing
that surprised me going through your
list is okay
be honest have you completed every anime
you've scored on here yes
no way no [ __ ] there's so [ __ ]
many
except for maybe son
you completed
[Music]
honestly think i have finished
everything because like i remember
one of because when we're gonna get to
my list one of the reasons why my list
seems
like a lot emptier is because if i don't
complete a show i just don't bother
putting in my list
right and well that's why i have like
the on hold section as well
oh you got the [ __ ] when did you stop
updating this man
you really were the anime man before
this what the [ __ ]
you watched so much anime yeah you've
also rated tokyo ghoul
season one the same as season two right
come on they are they are
to be fair i would rate what did i give
season one and do what do you think you
gave season one or two
i think i gave season one and two like a
seven maybe
you did okay yeah okay
i would give season two maybe like a
four yeah i was gonna say it's like not
even remotely the same
i give it like a photo i don't know what
i was on about
yeah i'll give it like a [ __ ] try
gunner seven you stand by that
yeah yeah really really okay there were
a lot of parts about trigon i really
enjoyed but i think the problem with
trigon is that i was a little too
over hyped when i came into it right
because i heard so many people being
like yo
trigon is like same levels as like you
know
barcano cowboy b-boy it's like it's like
up there with the big like classic
leagues yeah
all right i'll get into it and i watched
it and again it was good
but not to give spoilers but the last
quarter of trigon i was like
what the [ __ ] is going on yeah really
yeah really yeah i thought the last
quarter of tricom was [ __ ]
great it was great i enjoyed it but i
was like well i was like what the [ __ ]
going on i enjoyed it
yeah i mean it's been a long time i say
this i haven't watched it
in literally a decade yeah i think it's
been a long time
it's since i was trying on it uh tempest
as well
you gave that a seven that is that like
if there was a benchmark for seven out
of ten shows it would be
the tempest it would be no tempest i
actually i i
i can't remember what i wrote it's like
the one that's like a isn't it based on
the [ __ ]
it's based on shakespeare's yeah i mean
was it basically
because i think it was very very loosely
inspired of a shakespeare story i don't
remember which one it was but
i gave i gave her points because at the
time it was
quite creative and new i really liked it
like it's one of
i i put zetsune and the tempest in the
same category as i do darker than black
right when i watch when i when i watched
it it was kind of like
it when i think back i was like it seems
average in my memory but for some
but for some reason it sticks with me
and i always i always think back i
always think back to the show right
what did you see what did you see what
no i i did finish my point what yuri on
ice
were you just trying to get a like piss
off twitter that day
no i just genuinely thought it was
[ __ ] boring
i just thought it was [ __ ] boring i'm
sorry oh come on
i don't want to get into this again man
like at the time i got
so much [ __ ] remember for it
did you make an apology video yeah
no because people because i said that i
didn't like you
know you made an apology video it's
because at the time
at the time like uranus was like the
hardest thing right back like i don't
know i don't remember when it was like
2016 2017 something like that
and uh and all i said in the video was i
don't think euronice was uh
oh no i said something along the lines
of uh 99 of people watch euronice for
the yowie elements one percent watch it
for the actual sport element
and so many euro knife stands called me
homosexual because
oh sorry not homosexual call me uh
they called me uh uh homophobic yeah
they call me homophobic because of it
uh first of all hey i'm not homophobic
you also gave a free of five joey so
yeah man
pretty bad for this wow wow damn are you
because because free i gave a higher
score than uranus
because again because kyoto animation
animated that way better than they did
you're on ice i
i i don't really think there's any world
like any review that you could warrant
that
you're not just below a five like it was
a really good story
like it was it was minimum five i think
what would you give it what would you
give her
[Music]
i would give it a six
i think but like you could you
reasonably put it below a five like at a
four
i mean if it's not your thing because
the the thing about stories
the thing the thing about yuri and ice
is that they introduced way too many
characters
and they just like kind of didn't focus
on any of them also i'm sorry i couldn't
stand the main [ __ ] character
i love the guy who just came while he's
dancing that guy was funny as far oh
yeah that one yeah again there were some
funny parts
there's a reason why i didn't give it a
one right like there were some parts
about it
wow wow there's a reason i didn't give
it a one there's a reason i didn't give
it a one
there were some parts about it but like
was it a [ __ ] like slog
to watch all of it yeah no it was good i
was like
every episode pass i was like i could be
watching something else surprised and
beat you up for saying something like
that yeah
i thought you really liked it yeah no
she likes it and she's like well that's
your opinion all right
here's here's something i noticed all
right uh kisexis
oh yeah seven out of ten
yeah so dude do you wanna explain why
it's not either like a one or a ten
i'm guessing it's not a one because you
know he got you know he came to a
realization with his friend
yeah yeah yeah yeah no if if i put that
in my list
like after the first time i watched it
with my friend i would have given it a
10 right
right right then i rewatched it because
i was like i was
i was drunk as [ __ ] when i watched that
the first time let me rewatch it just to
double check
there's something and i was like it's
good not a 10 though
some of these anime i'm like why would
you subject yourself to this [ __ ] yeah
because back then
this is this is when i was like
literally watching
everything that came out attention all
phantom thieves
this episode is sponsored by afk arena
who are doing a persona 5 collaboration
which you can get involved with
right now unlike the super grindy rpg
games like we all know that i despise
because i don't like wasting any time in
my life
afk arena like the name would suggest
allows you to play without even playing
which is a dream come true that is
optimized to the max controller yes
for example i could be cooking sleeping
[ __ ] and i'll still be getting xp
for my kids i could be doing all three
at the same time and still because
i would be worried if you were man that
is just min maxing life
you could also be listening to the trash
taste podcast
auto collect resources quickly level up
in-game gear all while being busy you
can enjoy the various gameplay modes in
the game such as pve
dungeons arena king towers and more tell
me what you love about afk arena god so
what i love about afk arena as someone
who plays a lot of gadget games is that
there are some games where you probably
have to focus when you're grinding
but thankfully afk arena allows you to
skip all that afk arena has collaborated
with multiple properties before
including assassin's creed overlord and
now
persona 5. do you know persona 5 joey
yes it's only my favorite game of all
time wow
tell you what i never saw this coming
[Laughter]
kill me that's a joke right persona
right
you're killing me so yeah persona 5 is
one of my favorite jrpgs of all time
it's aesthetic it's funky
it's classic and it plays really well
and i love all the characters and
gameplay honestly everything about it
i enjoy the hell it is the aesthetic of
it it's just
kiss i have replayed that game about
five or six times
well persona 5 is a renowned jrpg for
its unique art style afk arena is also
known for its fresco painting-like
character design during the crossover
you can try out two of their newest
heroes
joker and queen which also happens to be
two of my favorite characters in the
game
so i'm extra excited well you can try
them free for three days
hell yeah there are ways to get them
completely free after but you can also
purchase the bundle to claim them
immediately if you don't want to wait so
while you listen or watch the rest of
the episode download afk arena right now
and play it at the same time
use code persona 5 for 500 diamonds 500
hero essence
500k gold oh my god links are in the
description so go and download it right
now thank you very much to afk arena for
sponsoring this episode
back to the video what i will say about
this going through this is that
you've finished a lot of shows that i've
watched like a few episodes of
and they're not going to be on my list
but you've like just straight up
finished them and scored them because
i don't trust someone who would get
through some of these shows
i'm like i i think there's something
wrong something's gone wrong in the head
so make you keep watching you have to
understand like back in like
2016 2015 this is all i [ __ ] did like
no [ __ ] wonder you burnt out anime
when you're like what when you're
actually finishing
most of these shows yeah like you know
in the movie old boy when that guy is
trapped in that room for like 10 years
like i'm pretty sure he watched less
anime than this like
like how do you okay yeah not gonna lie
like i'm looking through my list right
now and like
i i committed my past soul for the fact
that i finished infinite straddle season
two
finished season one you went through
season two
that you didn't lie on any of these that
you know like okay uh legit
other than sazai-san i hundred percent
have finished all these all right well
[ __ ] yeah
and that is like i swear i didn't like
grave a little [ __ ] reaction there
say [ __ ]
i swear i finished i mean overall your
list is like
exactly what i'd expected yeah like you
you give the shows that are universally
accepted to be good good ratings
right yeah is the university to be bad
bad ratings yeah i mean i have good
taste what can i say
the public tastes i don't think i have
the publicity
in life i gave you a nice three that's
far from public taste yeah you can't
just
just do one that was your one that was
your one whole take i wouldn't notice
you gave charlotte to seven
yeah and that's a pretty high score for
what i think yeah i would
in june my eight is like worst piece of
work yeah i would give that
realistically like a fire would you say
if the director is esteemed or like the
showmakers are esteemed you're more
likely to
give a fairer review i think if i'm a
fan
of like the the creator or like the
studio or like someone in the production
team
then i'm more willing to give it like
you know say like charlotte right like
that's a matter of june production
and like i love everything managing
makes but so i gave it a seven but
realistically thinking back on charlotte
now
realistically i give it like a four or
five so this is why i'm the perfect
critic because uh i just don't know
anything
you don't like anybody i go into the
show and um i don't even know what the
[ __ ] the studio made this like let's
just watch
yeah exactly so it's like bones who's
bones what is bones you gave another
nine
yeah what
what no you don't stand by that right no
come on i would still give it like an
eight
oh yeah i really enjoyed it i don't care
what anyone says i really enjoy but then
again i'm a [ __ ] horror anime simp
so that's like an anagram for i have
[ __ ] taste yeah that's what i like
because there is no good horror anime
what do you mean there's there's there's
everyone okay
i mean that's i risk my case that's
that's
that's a horror in the same way that
like [ __ ] monster is a horror you
know what i mean yeah monsters are
no that's that that's that's a horror
the same way that [ __ ] grave of
fireflies is a horror like it's
different kind of vibe bro what are you
talking about you know
i mean it's not like it's scary scary
you know it's kind of like this i don't
know man i was pretty [ __ ] on edge
when i watched modern okay
it's unnerving but it's not like like
it's definitely not on the same
kind of genre as another which is just
final destination
the anime adaptation but even campia and
i like the campiness of it i don't know
i really enjoyed it i love my [ __ ]
like
like to me another was like a really
good b great horror are
you trying to defend the [ __ ]
umbrella scene
yes how did you not burst out laughing
when that happened man
maybe because i watched it the entire
the entire last two episode
episode the entire last two episodes was
just a [ __ ] slapstick
yeah comedy i might as well
i really love the campiness of it i
don't know why all right
all right [ __ ] that i i completely get
why people hate another i thought i just
thought it was really
like tongue-in-cheek like camping right
right give me the box let me pull out
the next one all right so i'm gonna be
funny if i pull out myself
all right and the next list we're gonna
be discussing
is gone mine wow
i guess we're just going in order now
all right okay who [ __ ] needs it
i can't remember when i've last updated
this because i stopped updating my mao
and i
moved over the most recent and i moved
over to kitsu so it depends if kitsu is
also
updating this but um this is going to be
my teenage uh
taste i'm guessing sorry i i can i can
tell this is your teenage taste
because like i don't know in the past
episode you talked so much [ __ ] about
akira and
you've given it an 8 out of 10.
what would you give it now i'll give you
like a six a six okay i'll give you
you're still dead to me
what do you think you gave i can make a
kill
you're curious i was about to is it is
it really low
i'm just curious what would you rate it
today if i asked you to rate i can make
a kill
like two really two it's not that bad
yeah i i would also give it a second
it's pretty bad it's pretty [ __ ]
okay wait wait wait wait wait you gave
it four you gave it a four okay okay
good good
yeah teenage me i'd say okay i can't
make a kill was one of those shows
where i thought was awful and then all
the comments were
the manga's better the manga is better
trust me guys the manga is better so it
was one of those few times
why i call them on their bluff right i
called the manga readers on their bluff
and i read the manga up to the end right
and i'm just like
this is just the same [ __ ] just
elongated you know what i mean
everyone was complaining about the anime
only ending of a karmico kill
but the manga is like equally as edgy
but it just it just elongates
it just has a different ending and it's
it's it's
equally as bad in my view you also rated
alden uh zero yeah
you gave it a six yeah you gave that
season one to six and and season two or
six but season two come on it's
infinitely worse than season
one i don't know what i was thinking uh
season one i know zero season one is
actually like pretty decent i think yeah
yeah yeah
yeah you talk good of stuff about i'll
know i i don't know zero season one i
don't remember why
you maybe finished both of them at the
same time like you maybe
maybe i'm pissed off with the [ __ ] maybe
because because i remember i don't know
season one
being pretty interesting and then like
it was
it was great and then the cliffhanger
season ending happened and it was just
like
holy [ __ ] this is super interesting and
then season two just kind of pissed on
everything that season one he said she
became like kirito and stuff
like being the goddess i know this is
like teenage gods list because
okay dude
okay okay i i still stand by that yeah
it is it is
season two and eight as well season two
is not as good as season one
i've
it's like a comedy like kind of trashy
like romance itchy sounds vital yeah to
be honest i like it so i thought it was
really good
he was pretty good human ambassador for
domestic girlfriends he was right up his
phone
it was like one of the first comedy
anime that actually made me laugh and
i i didn't think was generic
and now that i look back i think yeah it
was probably pretty generic i don't know
like i look at the art style and i'm
just like this is premium mid-2000s
anime it is
nothing interesting to say about this
you gave uh baccano at 10 as well i like
that i like
that yeah i i i think we all get back in
our attention
on my list i don't know what that's what
that's why i'm curious to see what your
three by threes are because that's
that's where that's where like
the real personality test comes in hold
on i gotta ask that maylene
do we have beers oh no nabi gave me some
beers
okay i'm just checking i need to make
sure okay okay okay because it would be
fine oh no no we
we also have oh yeah we got the
pickering we also have piccara um
you like that like conor you're right
you like that
we we're gonna we're gonna be smashing
some of this
so i noticed as well that you also gave
uh batum an eight
yeah joey gave batum a six yeah yeah i
actually would side more with god on
this one
even though it did end kind of [ __ ] yeah
wasn't the ending absolute [ __ ] but
the show was really fun and the show
opening was a bang
opening [ __ ] ten out of ten dude
[ __ ] ten hour ten opening yeah but
soon the show
that was just pure fun i don't know like
it is
dude it was good it was it was [ __ ]
great it was one of the few death games
that didn't feel like it was one a uh
battle royale rip-off right because the
problem with every death game anime
is that it feels like of like a virgin
battle royale you know what i mean
that's real did it and like why would
you why would i want to watch anything
else
but soon just it was just like you
didn't try to pretend that i wasn't a
battle royale rip-off
but it just like really worked it went
off that and it just was a hell of a lot
of fun i don't know i think i gave it a
lower score i think when i first
finished it i
also gave her maybe like a seven or an
eight but then i read the manga and i
was like oh yeah compared to that wasn't
that great
i guess for some reason like batum has
always been one of those shows like
stuck with me i don't know why like i've
always just one of the season two i mean
yeah yeah i i always
i still think about it and i still think
about why it didn't have a season two
and like i i know sydney read the manga
and she said the manga is also pretty
good
yeah the manga is way better is it
actually good yeah the manga is way
better
yeah yeah okay you gave aramonga 10 so
you did to me
but you are my brother because you gave
ganks over 10 which i also agree with
yes
you gave code geoff season one to ten
and
code gear season two and eight oh what
are your thoughts on that okay
okay okay i'm interested okay i've okay
so i
i remember giving it a ten okay so the
thing about code yes right
is i gave it a 10 the first time i
watched it because i thought it was like
a [ __ ] masterpiece it was perfect it
was everything
uh i recently uh not recently like i
really watched code yes with sydney
and there was a lot of flaws in season
one that i guess i just
kind of ignored as a kid or just like i
kind of forgot about yeah
like okay like i remember re-watching it
and i'm just like
why is there an episode dedicated to
chasing a cat and how did i just blank
this from my memory
like that that
because i remember first watching coke
yes it was like easy 10 out of 10. this
is like
the greatest anime can become and i
think i just remembered the good points
of codekias because there was a lot of
like
plot holes and everything like it's how
can we spoil code geass
yeah i think i think it's you know i
mean we're gonna spoil cookies okay so
it's universally
it's okay it's like this gives skip to
this skip to this time stamp below
because code yes if you haven't watched
kgs and you want to watch it
it's one of the most spoilable shows um
out there but
i i remember re-watching it and i'm just
like man they were they really
they really had to like twist the plot
in order to make
nina or what was not nina um euphemia
just [ __ ] massacre
everyone right right because they
because i remember watching it i'm just
thinking
man the plot's kind of over now
everything's sorted and it was just
it was just the most racism is over
everyone go home it was just the most
roundabout way
of like okay guys we're going to make
the plot continue how can we make the
plot continue
and it was literally it was it was
literally a scene where lelouch goes
ha-ha wouldn't it be funny if i told you
to kill the japanese
ha ha psych x and and then and then it
wasn't like it did happen right
yeah and like and like i just i just
remembered
thinking well i remember thinking as a
kid that was a huge plot twist and now
watching is
watching as an adult i'm just like this
is stupid i'm just like
this this kind of this kind of doesn't
make sense this this is kind of pretty
pretty cheap right there
this is pretty cheap writing yeah um so
yeah like i would now i would give
code geass season one maybe an
eight i think because the highs of code
geos are so good
yeah like you you almost forgive it the
highs are very high so you like you
forgive it for a lot of the [ __ ] it does
yeah yeah
and then season two was like that was
that was
i don't know what it is about season two
that was like a car crash that somehow
yeah season two was a car crash that
somehow perfectly parallel parked
like it was
it was like absolute disaster and
somehow it like just
landed it landed its ending perfectly
and i remember re-watching cody's r2
after season one and i and aft going on
the problems i had was season one
season two just took all the like small
problems with season one and just
extrapolated to them
so like let's take every stupid every
stupid plot twist in season one and just
make it ten times bigger
true and i think the the exact moment
that lost me in season two was like it
was
it was lelouch it was the i am you know
i am spartacine but just with lelouch
and i just thought okay this this is not
this is not cleverly it's just stupid
and everything up to that till like the
final three episodes was [ __ ] dumb
but they just they stick the landing man
but like the ending is
still i think the best ending ever
inanimate
thing yeah i i i i would think i'd agree
with that i would think it's probably
the best of the top my head the best
ending anime has produced so far
so god was that an unpopular opinion god
no god knows god knows okay hold on a
second i'd like to point out uh for
someone who says he doesn't like
jubilee films he uh you gave mononoke a
10.
yeah will you stick by that because if
you do then i can high-five you but if
not
the backhand is coming okay um what did
i give spirited away
uh let me see because i
i think thinking back what an okay is
one of my you gave spirited away in nine
okay then yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah i i really had to
think about that
because i don't like ghibli films but i
think mononoke and spirit of the way are
some of the few wear
i i i i still good i still
like them i also love how you gave gyo a
six
that's pretty [ __ ] high if you ask me
i thought it was good
i just uh have you read the manga i have
read the monk how did you give it a six
first i
i watched i think i gave it a like yeah
it was like shinjito
is a ginger manga that uh and they made
a movie about it like five years ago and
it is
horrendous i i think it is i think it
was a fun movie
i i had a fun time watching okay i was
so sad watching it
because the thing about gyo is that i
watched the anime not knowing any
background about
it not knowing it was junji youtube i
thought it was just a campy b
movie horror movie which is which is
what it is
which it is but i remember because i
went into there thinking it was going to
be
absolute trash and i watched it and
despite it actually being you know
trashy
and it was trash it gave me the same
kind of enjoyment as you do watching a
shitty b movie
b movie horror yeah because it wasn't
like it was shitty animation because gyo
the movie was animated by ufotable yeah
and man they
you can see some effort being put into
this yeah but you also gotta admit that
like the the 3d
some of the 3d elements i was just like
god this is ugly but is that a good
thing because it's a horror like
i don't even know if in 2012 it wasn't
you know they weren't very good yeah no
it was compared to some of the 3d that
came out in 2012 compared to like
studio gonzo gans 3d which just makes me
want to vomit when i think
think about it don't remind me like like
it was it was good looking 3d
yeah sure like you fightable put some
effort into that and i and i
respect them for doing that uh you
watched halo legends
i think i think you're the only person
on my anime list who watched i didn't
even know there was an anime for halo
yeah oh my god
r.i.p to the other 19 000 people who
have rated this show
for some reason i think i watched i
think i watched that
that was my stint when i watched that
and the mass effect anime as well which
what do you think you give halo legends
did i say did i say what are you doing i
don't think so i didn't
i can't i i i had a a foregone
okay good good wow okay i i stick by
that hold on a second you gave
re-zero season one a six
did i actually oh no what's that about
oh okay why why this okay okay
i don't know why i gave it a six i think
i think it was because everyone was
hyping it up and i was
i want to be different i was kind of
underwhelmed by it right um now
i because i have rewatched zero in
preparation for season two
um i would give it a seven but i
remember
i remember coming out of re-zero just
feeling empty right
and it just it just kinda it just no
because
it kind of like i had a good f i had a
good time watching it and it just i it
was just like gut reaction of
it was a good time and i'm probably
going to forget this show in a few years
and it just it's just yeah i i didn't
end up getting it so
i i also gave space dandy a six as well
i really like space i really liked it
too i i if you
look at it like a saturday morning
cartoon it's pretty fun yeah
space dandy was it was a very hit or
miss for me
it was you gave sword online amazon
online 2 also was 6.
in god's opinion space dandy and sao on
the same level
on top of that he also gave uh guilty
crown of five so would you say that
would you say that sao is better than's
but going to sao versus space dandy i
mean
i i've rate this based on my pure
enjoyment and space standing was either
like nine on enjoyment or a two
depending on the episode which is
probably why i rated it at six
there was some killer episodes and then
there was some episodes that were just
a [ __ ] drag where sword art online
was just
was just like a constant it was it was a
plateau it
was it was just a constant six i watched
this i'm trash i enjoy this whatever
move on you know what i mean you care to
explain this one okay
jojo seven what's up with that come on
is it part one is it the original one is
there no no the original one he gave us
six which you also watched
season one well yeah actually you
haven't rated any other jojo's ever won
so i'm gonna take this to the jojo
series there's a whole garden okay no
i i rated part one well it's season one
seven it is it is a six i'll stick i
just want to get angry
i just wanted to you know get riled up a
little bit you also gave a totoro an
eight
okay that's wrong i don't know what what
the [ __ ] was i
thinking what they're trying to look
like i had good taste oh my god no it's
a [ __ ]
four what what do you think you gave
kuroko no basket
eight you did yeah i'm surprised i
honestly thought you would we would bash
krokor no more i love coraco
yeah for some reason i thought you hated
crap i love crocodiles no i i love croco
and
i it was my it was kuroka was a sports
anime that got me back into sports anime
um
so no i i i watched
all of makaku city actors yeah i noticed
that
he gave it a fall which i would also
agree with
what the [ __ ] how did you sit through
all that it was just
i don't know i liked the aesthetic and i
don't know why it was just
maybe i was just high that day and i
just i was so disappointed with that
because i love the novels yeah because
it's completely
[ __ ] destroyed it it was it was me
going through
it it was me after watching bucky
monogatari and going through the shaft
type right i'm just like this is going
to get better
this is my studio shaft i i legitimately
thought that
makaku city actors was like a gay porn
novel because of the internet
because all you ever see about makaku
city actors online is like gay stuff
yeah it is yeah there's a little there's
a large fujioshi fan base for mega city
and bro the opium kaka city actors is
the [ __ ] banger oh
i still listen to that [ __ ] it's great
all the time uh
what uh what do you think you you gave
monster
did i give it a 10. you did okay good i
honestly i would agree
i'd stand by that yeah i would yeah i
love monster yeah
it's one of those animes that like i
dropped and then came back to
yeah and that i was so glad that i
picked back up because it's obviously
it's really [ __ ] slow in the start
it is really slow but i feel like
monster is
of rarity of an anime where it's an
anime that has
an amazing manga that could have easily
be sliced up and have a shitty
adaptation but monster is one of the few
epic like masterpiece manga they got a
masterpiece adaptation
so i mean like thank god it got 70
something episodes that are dead yeah
yeah could you imagine if monsters are
twenty-four
that's why that's why i'm scared for the
20th century boys ever
gets adapted man because that's like
monster but even longer and even more
also i find it hilarious he gave
ikitorsen a too
is like imagine imagine like the
show that birth shows like high school
of the dead
it is a battle fan service show
and back in the day this was the most
degenerate kind of fan service the titty
action show you could do like so many
like weir boomers [ __ ] love ikito
yeah and guys just like
nope [ __ ] your memories it's [ __ ]
no i mean i look back now and maybe i'd
rate it higher i don't know it's uh
i i would rate it like maybe like a four
purely because it's just so tragic i
mean like back in back in the day this
was all we had you know
nowadays there's so much trash anime and
trash
kind of fan service he shows but back in
the day it was kind of like ikitosun
and then nothing else nothing really
else there's nothing like the guitar
you gave zetsuno tempest to seven as
well
yeah i feel like i need to watch it
again give your own isis seven as well
a try gunner nine that's fair yeah yeah
tokyo ghouls season one of six
and two google season
it's one of the shows where i don't know
if the manga readers are right because
everyone talks about the tokyo ghoul
mark has anyone have you guys read the
tokyo ghoul manga
no okay okay so nobody knows if the
if the manga readers were right for
tokyo ghoul but apparently it's one of
the most popular manga out there and one
the highest i find it interesting how
you gave dunmuch your five
yeah by that yeah it's it was it was
sword art online but beat us all out
online so i thought art online was like
why was that show so popular when it
came out i thought it was acceptable
i gave it maybe like a six so i was just
doing some passionate rant there right
now you thought it was good and you're
like i thought it was good
i thought it was acceptable and there
was a business prison school and eight
yeah yeah i stand by that prison school
is one of the most i mean like
disregarding the ending of the manga it
is one of the most hilarious mangas i've
met
i've read and the anime adaptation did a
pretty good [ __ ] job
you gave warren to sarah for five yeah i
wasn't sure if i should comment on that
i was like
offended by that not really man i've
never watched this i have no idea i'm
curious
psycho pass a seven yeah season one
really
really i know i thought no better no
it's uh nine now
yeah okay thank god like psychopaths i
remember psychopath is one of those few
shows that has
stuck with me and it's it's one of the
shows where i
re-watched it and i loved it
way more re-watching it than i watched
the first time because i think what's so
damn good yeah i think i didn't
appreciate psychopaths
the first time i watched it but the more
i watched psychopaths the more i'm just
like
now i like i gave it a 7 when i first
watched it and
when i was doing my when i was thinking
back to like my
top 10 favorite anime of the decade of
like the 2010s yeah psychopaths was up
there oh yeah
because it still has some like the
villain was one of the best villains in
anime
it still has some of the most unique
ideas
that i've seen in anime that has like
stuck with me and i don't think has aged
at all um
yeah like the like the scene halfway
through
where the main character has to make a
choice that that
has stuck with me for a long time and
the one scene that has also stuck with
me
is um i can't remember what exactly what
episode it is
but it's the episode where this
they start beating the [ __ ] out of this
character in like the middle of the
street
right and because of the system that's
been set up
no one reacts just because they they've
never seen something like this before
right
and i don't know i i thought that was
like such a unique idea
like that has that was completely
natural in this world that genorabuchi
has built
yeah um it's i think it's what the world
building is like yeah amazing i think
it's unfortunate
i think the biggest unfortunate thing is
that season two
and yeah i haven't watched season three
yeah but they just didn't have as
interesting ideas as what was in season
one but yeah
when you have like a giant calm it's
hard to like you know follow up
this video is sponsored by honey we all
shop online and we've all seen that
promo code field torn us at checkout but
thanks to honey
manually searching for coupon codes is a
thing of the past honey is a free
browser extension that scours the
internet for promo codes and applies the
best one it finds to your card
honey supports over 30 000 stores online
they range from sites that have tech and
gaming products
to popular fashion brands and even food
delivery right now you're talking gone
when i'm buying my cheap chinese cosplay
for that sweet youtube content you bet
i'm not paying full prices for those
pieces of garbage and thanks to hani
that's not a problem
saving money on garvey that's how we do
it here's how it works
imagine you're shopping at one of your
favorite sites when you check out the
honey button just drops down and all you
have to do is click
apply coupons and then wait a few
seconds for honey to find coupons that
it can use on that site if honey finds a
working coupon
you'll watch the prices drop damn that's
epic some of the cosplays are cheap but
i want them to be cheaper and thanks to
honey i've saved up to sometimes
20 dollars on some of those cosplays
which goes a long way honestly
when you're buying a lot and you're
spending half a grand on cosplay
it's a pretty good saving i'll welcome
it honey has found it's over 17 million
members over
two billion dollars in savings half of
that is on my cosplays
if you don't already have honey
installed you could be straight up
missing out on free savings it's
literally
free to install and takes seconds and
by getting it you'll be doing yourself a
solid and supporting this podcast
so you know what get honey free at
jointhoney.com
trash taste that's join honey.com trash
taste i
[ __ ] nailed that back to the episode
okay uh to end it off though i i gotta
point out this blast for me right here
yeah uh you gave the first pokemon movie
yep newton
yaksu a four out of ten yeah yeah yeah
you're [ __ ] nostalgia are you
seriously telling me the
the [ __ ] third movie the story yeah
the entire movie is better you've given
that a sec
you gave the ante movie more than the
first [ __ ] pokemon movie
i honestly i watched them as a kid and i
think i remember the
entei movie more i don't [ __ ] give a
[ __ ] about pokemon guys
this is all nostalgia talking here i've
i'm i'm talking
i rated this as an adult or a teenager
like yeah
years [ __ ] after pokemon man like get
get your nostalgia talk out of here
pokemon wasn't that great
i need to [ __ ] be a gun but again but
i'm pretty sure you gave
me more than eight okay yes yes yes
digimon is better than pokemon i will
fight you on this
i i was the digimon kid digimon the
first movie
was [ __ ] brilliant did you have an
amazing soundtrack the digimon kid is
like the og neighbors kid you know what
i mean yeah
that that meme of like oh go and look
after the neighbor's kid oh is he weird
yeah it's like he's a digimon fan you
know
i bet you were the kind of kid who was
like i don't play yu-gi-oh i play duel
masters
refuses to duel without the brakes yeah
exactly no
wait did you did either of you watch
digimon yeah i did so you so
i only watched i only watched the movies
okay but are you are you still sticking
by the way
i mean i watched them both at the same
age and i preferred pokemon really
yeah because digimon's digimon had an
actual plot
okay i think at that age that wasn't my
concern yeah
i think i think at that age the concern
is which monsters look cool
i think i think the thing was right is
that i would watch pokemon and then go
play pokemon and be like yo this is
exactly
exactly i would play digimon go and play
one of the [ __ ] disgusting rpg games
they have that was impossible to fit
did you have you ever played that yeah
some of them it's it's so
hard it's hard i can't even complete
that [ __ ] now and like 12 year old
like 10 year old me was stuck on the
[ __ ] thing like a first level i
couldn't do anything i'm like what sick
[ __ ] made this for a children's tv show
yeah because the thing the thing about
digimon and pokemon is that i never gave
a [ __ ] about the games
right right i didn't really i didn't
really care about the pokemon games
i i actually watched the pokemon anime
years before like i played the actual
games for the first time
really and the the thing that stuck out
to me for digimon was that
even as a kid i could recognize that
this had story arcs you know
like like like even as a kid i'm just
like what you are the most pretentious
[ __ ] no no no i was just this kid in
his [ __ ] diapers
in his phone like raping me on his male
list
turn this pokemon show off i i want
story in my children's shows
because i was always thinking to myself
why is ash not getting anywhere in his
life
i was angry about that as well yeah
everyone was angry about that but the
mewtwo movie
yeah i was good that had [ __ ] fanta
mewtwo was a fantastic [ __ ] character
like you could relate to that guy so
[ __ ] hard and then
you know with the whole like you can't
tell me that you didn't cry
i don't know when you watched the first
pokemon you did not you can't tell me
you didn't cry
with the pikachu crying scene i never
gave a [ __ ] about pikachu you're dead to
me
i know i never give a [ __ ] about ash
[ __ ] [ __ ]
it's it's it's a loud [ __ ] yellow rat
guys get over yourself
jesus christ
diabetic dinosaur i would i would insult
digimon but it's so
[ __ ] forgettable i can't even
remember anything i can only remember
what a [ __ ] name agumon what is that
yeah all i'm saying
is digimon was the original isekai
of course i'm gonna wrap digimon
i was born out my mom's woman i'm just
like mother is this a new world
yes it is i'm [ __ ] um i love i love
my digimon and as a kid
digimon was a bet is a better story than
pokemon and i will i will
hey guys make sure to uh follow us on
the trash taste twitter to just
absolutely [ __ ] all over this man's
opinions but uh moving on uh let's
go over to connor's list which is uh
brother beer first please um
do you want to be all right i think i
need to okay
take bullying from you guys every
has to defend his shitty take
well i mean it's kind of hard because
i'm looking at this list right now and
so far
there's a lot of shows that where you
haven't even given a score yeah i think
there's a lot of them i'm just like this
is so [ __ ] i don't even want to give it
a like hold up
don't [ __ ] tell me anything until
i've had my beer okay no i don't know
we're starting now we're starting now
it's hard you better prepare your
[ __ ] anus here
so like what was it okay justin
the [ __ ] buccaneer stan gave baccano
and mistakes
joey you'll taste the [ __ ] the job is so
much better eight out of ten yeah i
don't know why i did that i mean you
know really
clearly i was a fool i don't know who
that person is who signed into my heart
and changed my score
i love the fact that he gave bucky
monica a higher score than parker
weren't you [ __ ] on me for [ __ ]
liking clannad yeah
the first season is [ __ ] right what did
i give that you didn't even give it a
score
it's so [ __ ] forgettable that i
didn't even want to [ __ ] rate that
piece of [ __ ]
show bits if i could rate that i'd get
that like a seven or an eight that was a
fun show yeah that was great it's a fun
show
okay why the [ __ ] did i give c the money
of the soul and possible control in
eight yeah i don't know
i don't know why i did i never even
finished that okay okay
season one and two the same score wait
did i really yeah you did
second thing i immediately noticed after
our discussion like we just had
pokemon four
i thought you were my brother top top 10
anime betrayals of all time
i can probably explain why that is the
case right
because this was made in 2014. it was
probably the age of like
i'm a big boy now pokemon pokemon that's
that's old khan
that's child conor me adult connor i
don't like pokemon i'm a man i thought
you were my boy no i am i would
i would recorrectively change that to a
ten if i could
big sad really a 10 corner really okay
one one thing and one thing i find
hilarious right
come on okay so i didn't want to go last
because i can't
i have to talk [ __ ] about your scores
and not know my own connor has given
steins gate and sword art online the
same score
of eight yeah
you gave sword arts online season one
and everything
i think i'm actually having a strike
joey's just having an aneurysm right
[Music]
i'm not even gonna question you giving
steins get an eight okay that's fine
i meant to put ten yeah
i honestly you know what if i genuinely
i i enjoyed sold out online but if i
went back and watched it i'm sure
you know i would be like what the [ __ ]
is this [ __ ]
i enjoyed it for like what it was right
right i liked the idea because it's my
first ever like video game anime
right right so it was fun and then you
know you think about it more and
you think about kirito and you're like
wow this show is really garbage
but at that time yeah i mean at the time
everyone everyone's
i think we've all gone through the stage
where we thought sword art online was a
cool concept
back when it was a cool concert i mean
look admittedly as much as i'm known as
the guy who publicly hates sword online
like
i i've said that like first couple of
episodes really great build-up of the
premise
yeah and then it kind of just fell apart
after a while when they were like let's
make kirito the edgiest protagonist
alive and then that's when i was like
okay i mean you had a great premise yeah
and you just kind of ruined it with the
worst main character i have no idea why
i gave back and when i got three or nine
i would never ever do that
why would you give it like a five why
show [ __ ] what
boring show what that's boring man
that's so boring
yeah but you have to understand this is
a man who skips stories oh no yeah
so what i want to know is how the [ __ ]
do you watch bucky
why did you even watch it you watched an
animated light novel
yeah so i i watched back on the
gathering and then i watched like
the the next three seasons or so right
right and how did you
how did you manage that how did you
manage that i was confused a lot of the
time but i
i also just like thought a lot of it was
weird like is this the you have to bear
mind this is the first time i've ever
seen any anime where like there was a
protagonist or whatever he was just like
touching a kid
like the ghost girl and i was like i was
like whoa what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] is this i'm like well why
is everyone liking this child porn bro
it's all right man it's a deconstruction
of heroin
what i want to know is how you have the
patience to do it because even me
well again back in the age of like when
you're an anime fan yeah you can kind of
like put up with
anything because you've just gotten
right yeah and that was when i watched
it because it's always high up on the
list
and that that might have been the thing
that may be like you know what no i'm
not watching
but here's what he's doing here's what
confuses me right is that like
you gave back to it and i would assume
the
majority of the mono atari series like a
mid score yeah
but you love katana gator catholically
is like [ __ ] awesome but it's
the same style no yeah no okay it's the
same style
it's written by the speaker dude but it
but it's done like a million times
better it's so much more entertaining
than back among actually ever was i'm
not saying katanagata is bad
yeah they're both great because like i
guess
in my mind when i think of like katana
it just feels like a quentin tarantino
like film like when i like
right right yeah like the dialogue is
really important it's like one of the
like
i don't really like it when seeing how
how did you not find that with the more
of atari series because i didn't find
the dialogue interesting
in like captain agatha yeah like the one
selling point
i didn't find it interesting i was just
waiting
you know i was sold when i circulation
came on and i'm like yo this is a
[ __ ] bomb
and then i went i went to see it give
give us the [ __ ] yeah i need it after
i need it after the aneurysm i'm having
katana gathering right was like legit
oh [ __ ] okay i made my three by three i
honestly i didn't put katana i got three
innings i just didn't forgot i existed
that that would go in my three by three
yeah okay so katana is like
it gave me everything that like i love
about like kill bill and
pulp fiction in anime form and with a
kind of story with a setting that i love
which is like samurai i [ __ ] love
samurai
yeah yeah yeah i mean again i'm not i'm
not disagreeing with you on that 100
agree with all of them yeah i'm just
saying like
it's it's both a lot of words it's both
like
it's both weird yeah it's both
characters there's a very studio shaft
no katana gutter is not studio shaft
something about katana
i just really [ __ ] enjoyed so much
more than i ever did the monogatari
series
i think that's the closest you've come
to enjoying just reading words then yeah
yeah because i think because there was a
lot of the action
was really [ __ ] good and it made
sense all in the story
you didn't like the action in the modern
times the monogatari series actually was
[ __ ] [ __ ] insane
come on man it's i don't know why but
yeah the action was far better than it
had any right to be yeah exactly shaft
was like all right i'm a flicks real
quick
like that that that fight where it was
like araragi versus like
i think it was karen in the second
season yeah it was like the big brother
versus
i can't even remember no no no no the
fight was uh khan bar
that was brutal man i don't even [ __ ]
remember this okay
i'll show you afterwards and you'll
you'll learn appreciation i will say
though the toothbrush scene is probably
the thing that made me like curious
about hentai i was like i was like oh
this is actually
kind of hot yeah honestly like the
toothbrush scene it's not i'm saying
it's hot
it i i feel like it birthed so many
degenerates yeah yeah yeah definitely
because
that's culture was born and that's
culture was born thanks to the
toothbrush team that is a classic scene
i
who are you and how much time did you
spend on tumblr
honestly i don't know what mindset i was
in
to ever give there was i don't think
there's any point in my life where i
genuinely like nora gary in my opinion
the only 10 out of 10 aspect about
origami is the opening
yeah that was good but then again i find
it absolutely hilarious
that you gave black butler a 5.
honestly and you gave black butler
season 2 specials a
three honestly i still yeah i still
would really yeah
everyone i i made it no i didn't i would
not try and hide it that i did not like
the show your life is a lie i see wwva
fans he was never a black baller he was
never a black follower
you gave mona guthrie second season at
10.
i definitely suffered as a team getting
into anime
like i was heavily influenced by what
everyone else was i mean i agree
i agree i am a liar
definitely getting these them on a
guttery attendant as well yeah
this is definitely the case of teenage
connor saw that everyone was saying the
show was good that i didn't understand
so i'm just going to put it yeah i can
tell because you gave uh
mirai nikki a nine did you actually i
think i really enjoyed that show when i
watched it oh man
i'm legitimate you must have watched as
a teenager
that was like the elephant league again
this is your first generation
he was such an edgy kid listen listen i
was like that too when i finished
yeah when i was 14 that was seven years
ago so i was
i thought you just said how old was i
when i was 14
i was 17 yeah 17 when i made this list
yeah
yeah this sounds about right for 17 year
old connor like dead man wonderland and
eight yeah that checks out
okay you gave monster a seven
um what what i'm gonna have to download
okay that might have been
that might have been from me having to
recover from the fact that i dropped it
and had to pick it back up
you dropped it about yeah about 10
episodes in because the [ __ ]
didn't [ __ ] move but then actually
but then you when you watch it and
you're like oh wait [ __ ] it's good
holy [ __ ] nevermind oh [ __ ] oh hold on
hold on
but now like i gave cowboy seven as well
which honestly
you know maybe it's an a but it's it's
honestly it's not 10 or not there are
some shows on here that i'm surprised
you watched at all like zombie loan
zombie loan i have no idea why i watched
that show but i remember being angry
that i watched that [ __ ]
i remember being like mad that i wasted
my time watching the only reason why i
watched zombie alone was because i heard
it was a peach pit
show and i was like i like peach pits
i gave school days of one though yeah i
see that i see that
you finished sunday without god yeah
yeah i noticed that
i haven't finished that i finished it
but i definitely did not give it a seven
and he gave me seven wait which one's
sunday without gobbling exactly
that's that's that's the point i'm
trying to make
yeah with the show oh yeah i watched
that because i'm surprised you watched
that
that was when i i can actually tell you
the exact time i watched that i remember
very very
when i watched that so that when i first
got into anime i was watching it on like
the shitty like pirate sites figuring
out what the [ __ ] was going on yeah i
accidentally watched full metal
alchemist twice not realizing like what
the [ __ ] i was doing
and then i finally got a free trial for
crunchyroll
and so i watched as much anime as i
could for the 48 hours right
and that was one of them we're not
sponsored by crunchyroll
actually that was that was one of the
ones that i i watched and that was
zombie along one of them as well
no no no no that was before so i
remember that was probably the first
ever 12 episode show i watched on
crunchyroll i think right right
it's some of this just doesn't make
sense you watched the outbreak company
yeah i did yeah that's that's i would
never expect you
i would not have paid conor to watch it
i think you're the only other person i
know that has watched out
you finished the world god only knows
and gave it a nine
yeah all three seasons i actually really
liked it i really liked it i liked it as
well that just that just doesn't seem
rising
i'm just like my jaws on the floor
because if you were to tell me that
conor finished this show and lights i'm
just like
what is this wait you also gave
higarashi an eight uh
season one yeah uh i think i would take
that back
what would you give it now i watch the
dubs so maybe a four
like like i'm looking i'm looking at
some of this and i'm just like is this
me
right like he gave devlius a part-timer
a [ __ ] 10.
i love that i love dude that's really
good that is really good
if you actually look at my account my
profile picture is devil's apartment
i i loved it i loved devil as a
part-timer i'm surprised as well you
watched
the east yeah i did and the two movies
and gave all them a nine
i've really enjoyed eating of these
really how have we never talked about
eating of these together i don't know
how we never talk because i [ __ ] love
you it brings up even though these never
come it's a great [ __ ] yeah but no no
one ever brings that [ __ ] up it's a
great it's got a great first season but
like the movies just didn't
conclude it in the way i wanted to but
like he gave both of them a nine though
i i thought eden of the east had one of
the most interesting premises
oh yeah i watched okay since no one's
talking about eating of the east we're
gonna sell what you do let's do it
let's give some love to you guys i'm
gonna be honest i remember i i
remember my feelings for the show i
cannot [ __ ] remember what happened
well i i have one memory of this show
and it was like a ship and a bunch of
naked people coming
yeah yeah yeah that's all i remember no
no the the ending of
the the ending of the first season of
eating of these was [ __ ] great oh
[ __ ] pretty
so what is the premise again okay so so
so the premise is they have a smartphone
and i can't remember exactly how much
money they were given but you have like
13
13 people who were given these
smartphones and on a smartphone
you had like this ai that they could
request anything to happen that's right
right and they were given a budget of i
think 10
10 million dollars always more than that
was it like a million or 10 million
billion yeah 10 billion yet which is 100
million dollars
so they were given a budget of 100
million dollars and all there was there
all they were told
was to save the world yeah right there
that and that was their objective so
good and so
and so the series is just the story of
these different people
and their own take on what a hundred
million dollars means
to save the world and honestly like i
don't want to spoil
it but it's [ __ ] great especially 12
episodes
it's not just it's not just 12 episodes
it's 12 episodes and a movie
two movies two movies yeah are you sure
are you sure it's two movies not just
one
yeah because he gave both of them uh
nine out of ten okay
but i i feel like the first season was
[ __ ] fantastic
yeah it's and you know the problem with
the first season is that it didn't
conclude the story but the first season
was [ __ ] fantastic
um the movies were not as good in my
opinion
i don't know i didn't even know they had
movies yeah i don't remember much about
what happened in the movies
some of these shows i legitimately can't
remember like fully watching i just i'm
just surprised you what like you watched
hinted
the stoney cat and the the hentai aussie
i did watch that yeah yeah i think
you watched it as well that doesn't seem
like a show you would watch
why have we never talked about it you
watched black bullet you haven't rated
it but you watched that you watched
black bullets yeah i watched
all of black bullets
yeah i remember i i actually do really
enjoy like
uh like romance slice of life shows but
i used to binge them all the time
yeah yeah yeah now i you watch black cat
as well yeah a black house [ __ ] though
yeah the mother was white i watched
gachaman crowds and i remember
i that was i gave that a six but that
was so reluctantly like i i did not
enjoy
watching that and i watched there's a
bunch of other shows that i watched
after this i didn't include like what's
that [ __ ] card game like wick sauce
or whatever it's called
sauce yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah i'm angry
though watch
that i hated that i watched that why did
you even watch that this is the thing
right is it
to me i didn't i do not like looking up
anime like i don't want to know anything
about the show right yeah give me the
[ __ ] show let me watch it and if i
hate it just brain dead yeah i want a
dead monkey boat like if you if you
because here's the thing right
i guarantee if you just give me a show
tell me to watch it i'll watch it i
might enjoy it
if you try and sell me on a show i
immediately will
start being like i don't know no i'm
completely the opposite yeah i'm the
opposite because like i've gotten to the
point
where i need to be sold on the show
because i i need to have like a reason
why i'm watching this show like is this
show going to get good am i going to
have something i get out of this show i
i
i need to i need to know that before i
get before like truly get into a show
because otherwise
nowadays i end up dropping shows after
one episode if it doesn't hook me even
like
critically acclaimed highly claimed show
if i if i don't know
that something good is coming up that's
going to be worth my time yeah then i'm
just not going to give it a chance
because i just don't have that patience
anymore i've sat through enough shitty
shows to know that i don't want to waste
my time anymore yeah yeah exactly right
and you know it's it's just it's just
sad because i i do
miss that feeling of finding hidden gems
where i can just be like oh i have zero
expectations exactly exactly
i gave kyo uh wait there's this one yeah
one thing that's curious to me you
watched phase zero but you rated
the second season lower than the first
season
you mean the the the actual
action-packed second season where
everything gets concluded
it's lower than the first season yeah
which is the setup
you're like you're like completely going
against everything like
all the character build up you've
brought yourself up to right it's like
oh i
hate story i love action but the season
where there's more action i'll write
lore yeah
i really enjoyed when they were
introducing like all of the characters
in in faith that's like my favorite part
of faye right
and fate's day night as well my favorite
part of fate day night is when they're
introducing the characters
because it's so cool because you're like
i know i know there's an assassin i know
there's a writer
what are they gonna be and then when and
then when you watch fate stay night and
you're like wow ryder's [ __ ] in this one
compared to fate zero
because like fate zero you watch you're
like yo ryder he's the best alexander oh
i'd [ __ ] him
but like then you watch then that's the
reason why i [ __ ] hated fate stay
night except for the animation
because i was like which face they know
are you talking about
talking about the original face okay
okay
the series not the movies right the
series okay because
i don't want to get into this review the
point is
i just need clarification because what
you saying fans were like on their seat
right here
aren't you cool but i can't believe they
had like there was no like good alec
they should just brought alexander back
again and be like hey i'm back baby or
like it's a pre-course i guess like hey
i'm i'm back in the future yeah yeah i'm
back here
i'm back in the past yeah because that's
he was like the best part of we zero
relationship with the [ __ ] uh the
weevil whatever he's called
the [ __ ] weevil waver wave
there's a lot of ones that you haven't
given a score darker than black i stand
by being a nine because if you watch the
dub dude troy baker is in that this is
before troy baker stopped doing anime
yeah i'm like
[ __ ] man he kills it as november 11. oh
yeah so [ __ ] i i
i've like darker than black is a show
that i've actually re-watched quite a
few times and i don't know why i've
rewatched quite a few times
i really i just really liked the world
of darkness yeah
you know what i'm not gonna lie i don't
remember anything it's like quirks but
if they were actually [ __ ] cool and
weird
yeah yeah like cause cause like it was
like i remember watching it it was like
x-men but what i found interesting was
the fact that they had to like do this
really weird activity every time they
used
their power and i just know smoking yeah
i don't know why i just thought that was
really cool and
like it has a [ __ ] amazing soundtrack
as well because it was like by yokocana
and i feel like
one of the biggest differences between
the first season every other season was
yoko kana's music just set such an
amazing tone for this world
and this environment that it just made
you just it it just felt good
exploring this world and just being in
it i feel like i gotta re-watch it
it's fun dude and watch it dub dude like
the dub's really [ __ ] good
you're saying this to joey now honestly
honestly dude like troy baker is
november 11.
i love troy you all saw me on because
troy baker plays the guy who has to
smoke even though yeah he's smoking yeah
i've watched it as well
so good man oh god um okay well
hold on you watch saki uh yeah and you
gave it a seven
sakisaki that's the one with the things
on his ear that's the yeah yeah another
the the the major one yeah that's the
the body pillow we have yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah i watched that
you've you've actually watched it i
didn't watch i watched
all of saki and i i hope at the end i
was like i'm gonna understand
and at the end i was like i don't
understand myself i'm like but there's
golden wind and [ __ ] going on and stuff
like that
i don't know so okay again it just
doesn't seem like a show you would watch
i watched all of persona 4 the animation
i noticed that i noticed that as well
i've never played persona 4 played
persona why why would you do that
i didn't i i'll i'll be 100 with you at
the time i legitimately didn't know it
was a game
that's like that's like that wait did
you watch danganronpa as well yeah yeah
he did he gave me
a play dungeon give it a four i have
played danganronpa
for the shows that i haven't rated you
can ask me and ask me what i'd give it
okay what would you give a no game no
life
oh that's if i was four if i was 14 yeah
i got a hard ten
yeah yeah yeah now like a seven on a
seven
okay it's it's it's it's about that what
would you give excel
uh you know like a like a four
what would you give another like a like
a one
all right another was [ __ ] well you
watched b got the hk as well you know
okay actually i
i did i love we gotta hit yeah that is
funny that's actually like a [ __ ]
gracious
i can tell you exactly why i watched
another as well uh because i was talking
to a girl at the time
and she was like of course my favorite
show is another
it's the best show and i was like all
right fine i'll watch this show because
i'm trying to like simp
i'm trying to sound pierced so i'll try
it yeah another was kind of like the
kind of like the true crimes documentary
the anime community you know what i mean
everyone knows white girls love true
crime
yeah and before they get into true crime
you know they're a little younger
they're like another
yes erased yes you know all these shows
that i love it's just like yes i too
like final destination and watching
trashy horror movies
i can do that all day long that's
literally what sydney gets me to do
whenever i'm like
okay i'll give you i'll give you props
though that you a watched claymore and
gave it a nine
honestly i loved claymore claim was
[ __ ] awesome
man i that is one of the animes that got
done most dirty yeah
that's that's what i'm surprised you
gave it a nine because claymore manga
manga nine or ten claymore manga
masterpiece anime
not much the anime made me like feel
things that i hadn't felt before man i
was like
what is that like a level of
uncomfortableness that i haven't i
haven't
experienced before yeah like i don't
know why there's something so unnerving
and uncomfortable about watching
claymore yeah
i i felt that when i watched berserk
yeah
it's like kind of [ __ ] it like [ __ ] you
up a little bit yeah i can tell like
i honestly i wish i i'm i'm going to try
my best to try and read the manga but i
said i was going to read something i
recently rebought all the mangas just
because i want to read it again because
what was the other [ __ ] show i said i
was going to read the manga earlier uh i
have no [ __ ]
no no you finished action 21 right yeah
yeah i did i wanted after that
well uh i i actually i downloaded uh
this first one was it no no no i was
going to read that but i actually
downloaded the first 30 chapters of one
piece
being like oh he's getting old
but i haven't i haven't stopped i
haven't had this stomach market
marketing your calendar
va starts with one listen i'll tell you
when i start like i'll
but i haven't marketing your calendars
and come back to us in 10 years time
we'll see where he is honestly like
claymore is
a [ __ ] amazing manga one of the best
mangas out there
anime did it dirty is the is the manga
finished like totally old
yeah yeah yeah okay good good 22 23
volumes yeah okay
and because like more anime had a anime
original ending
remember yeah and it was complete [ __ ]
from what i remember yeah
i remember having a good time i remember
i watched the dub and i remember the
voice acting was uh
greg as was like playing the whiny
characters he always does
and i think he was a little too whiny i
mean that's just gregaris
uh he's damn he's too [ __ ] good at
his job no no because like i remember
that that was like
i swear he was typecasting that rolf
like the longest [ __ ] because there
were so many of those characters and no
one else could do a voice like him with
like sounding whiny yeah and so it's
always him doing the whiny character i
will say a wrecker seven
seven out of ten honestly i when the
original one
when i watched that everyone was talking
about the show like jesus had came down
himself and brought a show
yeah and i watched it and i thought
honestly this is kind of [ __ ] like it's
it's good but like it's kind of [ __ ]
boring like is that
is that how you feel about it obviously
now i would give it a six is that how
you felt about ergo proxy as well you
gave that a seven as well
oh go proxy i remember i was just like
what the [ __ ] is happening
again this doesn't seem like an anime
that you would watch no like the
ergo proxy is the last anime i would
think it was like watching
like you know when you go to a modern
art museum and you look at this [ __ ]
you're like
yeah i get it
is like the same amount of like what the
[ __ ] i would get if you came up to me
tomorrow and said
so i watched uh serial experiments lane
yeah honestly i've been wanting to watch
that for a while i just
i just haven't had the the opportunity
to be like yeah i want to waste a day
yeah and not not really enjoy and have a
and i have a brain that's supporting
yeah i feel like you watch you watch
shows like that to come out with like
just your brain being like what
but like that's not fun half the time so
i don't know i mean
it is fun depending on your mood because
i remember like i
it took me ages to watch serial
experiments lane and then i was just in
this weird mood where i'm just like
yeah i i want my mind to be [ __ ] up
that that sounds like yeah
right now yeah and then i don't want a
challenge yeah it's it's like
it's like me with you ask me like i'm
wait i'm waiting to wake up for the day
where i'm just like
yeah i want i want depression right now
you know why the [ __ ] did i give
uh this anime mao mao yusha
i was about to say you gave that a nine
and i'm like okay
and i'm like was it the milf titties is
that what it is
that's all i remember from you know that
gets a little two bonus points but but i
think again that was in the same weekend
that i watched the other show on the
country will 48 hours right right
because i remember the mile mile yusha
was like studio arms and if you didn't
know if you don't know studio arms they
were like
they were like famous for being a hentai
studio well
like transitioned into anime well that's
probably why it connected a little bit
and um yeah i mean that was like one of
the first
shows they produced that was an anime
that was seen as just not complete trash
but i wouldn't call it a [ __ ] night
there's little sexual things going on or
something like that some vibes of little
milf step son i mean i mean that was i
i'd say as an impressionable teenager i
can see why you are
connected with that on a personal
he level with it but yeah i think that's
pretty much everything because uh
you haven't rated a lot of these i would
bump kill the kill at one
for getting me into hentai that's the
same thing i would really
kill the kill is what made me be like
you know what anime girls are hot i'm
like you know what this is a hentai of
this and there was
and that's how i was like oh this is
good that's why you need to get into the
ginsengs man
um we're gonna we're gonna get him into
that event yeah
eventually wait wait okay then if you
liked maui maul yusha did you like long
horizon
i loved logarithm is one of my favorite
shows okay that makes sense because it's
written by the same people
i'm actually hype even though i think i
need to rewatch a little bit of
logarithmic season two
yeah i remember i [ __ ] loved the
world yeah like in logarithms
like i don't know how they like [ __ ]
write stories like i'm glad
yeah i'm almost great i'm also glad that
the show didn't like [ __ ] blow its
load like immediately and yeah
stop telling us everything about it like
yeah i love it when the show's teased us
with the world like here's a little
crumb
yeah crumb knowledge and then they just
don't mention it for a few episodes
you're like oh [ __ ] yeah we are in a
we're in a [ __ ] video game
yeah because i remember log horizon i
remember
watching the first two three episodes of
it dropped it immediately
because i'm just like really what what
is this beta sword art online man
what the [ __ ] is this because like the
worst thing about
lockhorizon was that one like the
animation is like
it's like it ain't great it's like the
most typical
five out of ten animation this is just a
throwaway seasonal show
and the first three or so episodes were
like the most
generic kind of introduction you could
get to a world and it didn't start
getting interesting until they probably
started explaining
like the game mechanics and seeing
seeing the game mechanics being broken
like within this world was just so
[ __ ] interesting
yeah that whole arc where like there was
a guy who could kill in the villages
yeah yeah that was [ __ ] cool like
what really you sold me immediately was
like when they when they first
discovered
that they could make things taste good
and then they like invented the burger
and was like yo this is really [ __ ]
interesting this this isn't even an issa
car this is just like a
like an entrepreneur business [ __ ]
anime
basically just like a business textbook
yeah yeah how do you how the [ __ ] do you
guys remember what happens in these like
seven out of ten shows bro the moment
something isn't like exceptional i'm
like that's going into the
locker rise is not a separate
was cool because again it was like again
it's done by ton of money who's like
somehow can like
make you learn [ __ ] while reading these
stories i don't know how he does it
i think it's like spice and wolf right
it's like spice and wolf exactly like
the reason why i love spices
because because like i actually learned
like proper like
useful business skills like wait a
minute i'm just getting horny over this
one or if this wolf wife
but i'm like who's the marketing genius
but i'm learning things about economics
that's not la that's not legal that's
not allowed
what are you doing i can't be horny and
smart at the same time that's not how
that works
i just feel like i have like amazing
brain compression like i
my my brain zips zips like
you know how like when you compress a
file to like lower the memory it takes
up that's what i do with anime
immediately when i'm done i'm like zip
that [ __ ] up put it in storage forget
about that thing
and then when when i rewatch it it's
like unzipping the farm like oh yeah
this did happen yeah
has this man like min maxed his brain i
actually think i actually think i've
i've
you know i've sorted the storage on my
brain apparently you've
you've got a sorting algorithm literally
just for anime
my [ __ ] god but yes i think this is a
good time to move on to
our three by threes now yes there's a
reason why i have my laptop up is
because we're gonna create uh three or
we're gonna
share each other's three by three of
anime yeah we've explained that
we've explained what three by three but
like to expand further on that i
i like i love seeing people's three by
three right because
i feel like a three by three is the
closest thing you get to a rorschach
test for like anime fans
you know you know you know what i mean
because you get you get to see
because like like asking someone asking
what someone's favorite anime is it's
like a [ __ ] stupid question because
like if you've seen enough changes all
the time it changes all the [ __ ] time
but like
with uh with like a with like a kind of
with nine anime to choose from
that's a good sample size to really get
a grasp on what this person's taste is
like not not
not if all their taste because i don't
know how hard a time you guys had
choosing nine anime i
just shoved three together again that i
like but i had a pretty difficult time
just choosing mine anime
well you have a [ __ ] d you probably
have like a seizure just thinking like
what am i gonna do for like breakfast
like oh my god like jesus christ
like i swear you you like take so long
to contemplate decisions
i mean i came up with mine pretty
quickly just because like i literally
thought of the first night we're gonna
look at mine first
but i literally just thought of the
first nine that i think is like
yeah i love this yeah because i think
that's the most important thing is like
i feel if you think too hard about it
then you're
kind of reshaping your tastes too much
it's just generally just a bad policy
yeah
so i was i was like all right what are
the nine shows that i [ __ ] love
thinking thing you're just a bad point
don't think i personally think thinking
is overrated i'd rather just go with
guts is that an unpopular opinion
i'm gonna say it unpopular opinions
thinking is overrated all right so let's
look at mine first all right
let's let's see what you got here joey
lucky star clanna yo what the [ __ ]
to the audience who cannot uh see or
don't go to these shows what they say so
from so the top row from left to right
is serial experiments lane clan ad fully
equally
why lucky star i i've gotta ask my my
why why
okay
okay don't don't worry about placements
too much
like don't worry about placements too
much this could be in any random [ __ ]
order
yeah reason why okay i completely get
why someone would look at me and say bro
lucky star is not good
because truth be told if you watch lucky
star today
it'd probably be [ __ ] right lucky star
to me
is so time sensitive because all of its
jokes
are time sensitive like lucky star was
one of those shows that
made fun of like otaku and weeb culture
back in like the mid 2000s
i'm turning this into a [ __ ] like
video essence i'll tell you what [ __ ]
lucky star is my friend
lucky star is uh reddit humor before
reddit existed
that's it's it's it's like the it's like
the late 2000's reddit here
and the reddit just didn't exist so
everyone's just like oh lucky sounds
amazing yeah exactly
i couldn't sit through it really yeah i
didn't finish it i see like
it's weird because randomly like a
couple of days ago i was just scrolling
through youtube and on my recommended
there was just like
a lucky star like funny complimation and
i was just like yeah [ __ ] i haven't
heard of lucky stars i
it was like six minutes long i'm like
you know what [ __ ] it i've got time that
sounds
like an oxymoron to me lucky stuff funny
compilation
but i don't know i think it's because
like especially around the time when i
watched lucky star i was like
really heavily into obviously of course
like anime obviously but yeah
i was really heavily into like the otaku
culture especially in japan
yeah and lucky star kind of went over
all of that [ __ ] and put it into
perspective of like
it's pretty [ __ ] ridiculous looking
from an outsider's perspective
yeah this cafe is weird huh yeah no not
even that it was just like
like the [ __ ] comic head scene is
still funny to this day just because
it's so accurate
i mean i just i looked back at lucky
star and i never liked it originally but
i look back at some of the scenes i'm
just like
yeah this doesn't age well to me at all
right exactly and that's why i
never recommend lucky star to people
today yeah because it has not aged one
the jokes have not achieved i have a
question
what the [ __ ] is this show in the bottom
corner i've seen this swan the bottom
left yeah what is that shirt
what's the english name for that shirt
uh [ __ ] uh
god i haven't even i think i've watched
that show it's basically
it's basically like a comedy show that
throws in a lot of itchy jokes
i've watched the show and i don't
remember anything about it i 100 have
watched this show
and i i i'm one small girl the small
girl's angry that she doesn't have big
tits right a lot
right that's one of the jokes yeah he
funny
okay why why is this in your three
people three this is in my three by
three because a well first of all
i think it's [ __ ] hilarious b it kind
of encompasses
my love for comedy and my love for itchy
you have a broad term of what comedy is
yeah um lucky stuff what what what
encompasses your love for
comedy uh what what about the show
encompasses your love for comedy i think
it's [ __ ] hilarious
i mean i don't know what else what the
[ __ ] answer were you expecting no
it's because it's very intricate and the
jokes that constructed are very
like this this okay the reason why i put
this in
is because it encompasses my love for
trashy shows this show
is not good in any perspective i'm just
saying it right now all right
here's how you know that my three this
is how you know my three by three is
legit right
give me some of this
is not a good show it is trashy shitty
comedy with etchings
it's crap all right okay here's the
reason why i put it in
important question then every show in
here yeah would you rewatch it today
yeah you would i would you re-watched
lucky stuff
i i did i'm not just saying he literally
just said i was literally watching a
compilation two days ago i just thought
it was a lie honestly i just didn't
believe it
i would 100 re-watch all these shows
today i gotta say i was like
i didn't put it on but i was this close
to putting you hacker show away
i am glad that you put it i put your hot
show in because it represents
my love for sure i gotta be honest right
boys i legitimately tried to watch you
hack show
no less than a week ago right i put it
on first episode and i was like
[ __ ] i can't watch this like i thought
it was the dub and i was like the dub's
too awful i switched to japanese i'm
like [ __ ] it's awful as well i can't
stand why why don't you talk
great what are you talking about the
audio was driving me insane like i
actually couldn't watch it
it was such bad quality i know that it's
old but like i actually couldn't sit
there so basically your review of you
hot show is where it's old
no no honestly like i feel bad that i'm
like that but like i was like [ __ ]
actually i'll read the language
oh my god you're really gonna hit me
with that audio problems
what was your what was your problem with
the audio because like you hug show from
what i remember was like one of my
favorite dubs
it really i don't know i never watched
the dark side i swear
10 seconds into the job i'm like [ __ ] i
listen to the japanese i gotta say i
gotta send it i gotta turn this [ __ ] off
like
seriously yeah it was pretty good who
the [ __ ] played yusuke because yusuke
[ __ ] like killed him this is probably
just a case of you know
you know watching it years later and
being spoiled for choice et cetera et
cetera i mean for me okay
like i put you hutcher there because hey
obviously i love
my shonen but i feel like i don't know i
have never felt
the same level of excitement that i felt
watching and writing
that i have from any other i'm i'm
envious i want that yuei hakusho has
some of my favorite arcs in all of
shonen the dark tournament arc
tuesday one of the best arcs in shonen
no
the dark tournament arc is the best
tournament arc
hands down of all time hands down and
this is this is a tournament arc that
came out [ __ ] 20 years ago now
like it it birthed the tournament arc
genre yeah the reason
why the reason why tournament arcs have
become a meme and
are so hyped is because of you it's
because it's because of you
like dragon ball might have like
popularized it but then new york should
perfect
it yeah it hasn't been perfected since
then but like
also like sensui is one of the best
villains in all of shonen as well oh
yeah and togaro as well
oh my god such a good character not
gonna lie growing up i wanted to be
he a so bad i was like i looked at hie
and i'm just like everything about this
guy
with the black hair
is so [ __ ] cool is there's a serial
experiment laying at the top yeah that's
the
top left why i think because like
well again i still think it's [ __ ]
insanely ahead of its time like this was
made back in like
the late 90s and it talks about [ __ ]
societal issues that are relevant today
right and that's i don't know i think
that's like a huge artist
what kind of stuff does it talk about in
the show what kind of society so
basically to
grossly oversimplify serial experiments
lane is essentially this idea that
your digital identity and your real-life
identity
sees no barrier okay and so basically it
follows
obviously lane who kind of goes through
this like discovery of herself
and the world in being like wait so we
can
create digital identities of ourselves
on the quote-unquote internet i mean
obviously back then it was very primal
yeah right but it came out in like 1999
98.8
yeah just just didn't even have balloons
tower defense exactly
yeah this is the full flash player [ __ ]
but basically it's it's this idea that
like
wait so if things happen in the digital
world
then is there really no consequences of
that in the real world and vice versa
and they did that in 12 episodes and
it's it's
i i i will attest that ex experience
lane is [ __ ] amazing
because i remember well i watched it for
the first time last year
so i watched it pretty much oh really
yeah yeah well because it was unlike to
watch this forever yeah and then i was
just like you know
i'm finally in the mood to watch this
i'll give it a watch and i remember
thinking man
this normally when you see a piece of
media that focuses around technology
and like stories around technology it
ages
horribly and i remember watching zero
experience lane i'm thinking
how is this how does this seem like it's
more relevant now
than it is when it first came out
overlapping
because like this shows 20 years low-key
foretold
the future of social media yeah yeah
yeah
i think i think i can understand that if
you were really in touch with the
internet back then you could probably
see where it was going i think
and and i think and i think and
obviously i pick serial experiments
laying there obviously because i love it
but also
i love i mean the shows that make you
think
quite unquote yeah yeah that to dive
more into that kind of stuff like yeah
you know yeah make you thunk right like
ergo proxy is in the same field as that
yeah i love that show and uh you know
razorfan as well was in there as well
yeah and planet i mean i just think it's
good
maybe cry like you made me cry they both
it's seven episodes and it feels like a
[ __ ] five hour long movie
it's it's a very dense show very i would
say
it does not why does dents always just
sound like an insult
it's a dense [ __ ] it's a
fictional what do you want to say no no
it's it's a it's a compact show
compact sounds less of an insult than
dense dense sounds like it's like
like brick [ __ ] house like filled with
like garbage
okay it's it's a compact show no i'm
listening
there is like fully [ __ ] has 24 i
would
say 24 episodes worth of material packed
into seven episodes i would agree with
that yeah
and it's good one of the best
soundtracks of all time soundtrack is
[ __ ] amazing it's
pillows [ __ ] amazing yeah i have no
more questions you're free to go
yeah okay no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no
you had a choice of any anime movies and
you pick
a ghibli movie i mean look man you gave
this a 10 out of 10 was it on your list
i mean
and you also didn't change that score if
it's a good movie
would i put it as like an anime movie is
the best anime movie go on
he's going to say your name you're going
to find out
uh when i when i get yeah let's let's
check out shall we let's
let's let's let's check out mine jump
right into it let's jump right into it
let's check out mine and see what you
guys see there
oh my god all right well
we can we can ignore the filth in the
middle but um
honestly in the
let me spell out my three by three yeah
so from
uh top left uh going down uh
row by row yeah so you've got your name
bacano
one piece uh haruhi or the disappearance
and black league god this screams
someone who got into anime in the 2000s
jesus christ look at this screams yeah
yeah look at this [ __ ] black lagoon
evangelion and haruhi on the scene
okay not gonna lie i'm not gonna lie i
was not expecting black lagoon
to be there i i i could see it really
okay so there's nothing like it i've
never heard anything about black living
coming it's [ __ ] good no it's great
i'm just curious
it's it's [ __ ] brilliant it's one of
the shows that i haven't had too much of
a chance to talk about but like before
before i get into that
let me let me let me tell you the
thought process
[Laughter]
let me tell you too much emotion let me
tell you the thought process i
put into like picking pictures because i
i
you know at the beginning i was like how
the [ __ ] do i pick my favorites because
i have like too many favorites right i
can talk about
right so then so nice so then i thought
okay
here's here's a big thing what if i just
pick the anime
that i have re-watched okay because if
if i've rewatched something and this is
like re-watching not for my job but
re-watching for my own enjoyment
if i've re-watched something that means
there is something
[ __ ] special about that show that has
stuck with me that i've felt
like i've wanted to go out of my way to
re-experience i
agree with that and enough even even on
some shows that i think is [ __ ] great
like for example like stuff like monster
or like
highly critically you can claim shows i
do not want to re-watch no no like
exactly i i feel like it's had his time
in the sun but
in terms of like what i truly like enjoy
to the core
i wouldn't go out my i at the moment i
wouldn't go out and re-watch monster you
know
i i wouldn't do that no okay hold on but
i get that right yeah like i'm looking
at this right now being like yeah
re-watch that re-watch that yeah
would you re-watch one piece i have
re-watched one piece is it even possible
to re-watch okay okay i've i've okay
here's the thing
i've got that steins gate time machine
or some [ __ ] how are you doing okay i've
watched one piece or
basically up to up to the time skip all
the way once
and then i've rewatched it again once uh
and then i've re-watched some of my
favorite parts
multiple times i [ __ ] know it is and
this was back when i had time to watch
anime
and i would just like whenever i go
whenever i have time like i said when
you said you really watch right i
thought you were talking about like oh
i've rewatched the water seven
i've re-watched alabaster i didn't think
you really watched you've really shown
your age you need years to re-watch that
now
one day no wonder you're older than me
like [ __ ] me you need like i love how i
love how you compensated me like no no
only up until the pre before the time
i'm like it's still like 400 percent
okay
which is why like i was having trouble
putting a shonen on because i'm just
like
is there any shonen that i actually
truly loved that i would you know
think that i would go back any time
because i was going to put you hug show
and i was thinking
seven deadly sins come no yeah i'll come
here for 737 right
but like one piece to me will go down
when it finishes will go down as
one well it already is one of the
greatest anime slash manga series of all
time yeah of course but to me
when i think back and i think back
because one piece isn't the perfect show
right yeah i've rewatched one piece
does anyone claim it is yeah i know like
everyone everyone forgets about the lows
of one piece where everyone forgets
about like [ __ ]
sky ellen sky island i wasn't a fan of
the foxy arc which was a filler cannon
arc that everyone doesn't talk about
you know you know what i mean what are
these names
these things don't sound [ __ ] real
was like
um it was way too long it was dragged
out to [ __ ]
but nothing in my opinion can touch
the highs of one piece when one piece is
at its best
right i i think it is the greatest
the greatest thing you can find in anime
i will stand by and say even though i've
watched every minor june anime yeah i've
cried more times watching one piece
than any other [ __ ] when you have that
many episodes something's gonna hit
right yeah like [ __ ] me
but i mean i wasn't excited i mean like
there's plenty of shows that have a lot
of episodes
and haven't had the highs that one piece
happens because
how do you know anything about this
pokemon has some pretty high highs man
but like
what i find amazing about one piece is
it's been going on for like what 20
years now
almost 30 now almost like i can't
remember when it's like i think it
started in the 1990s
98 or 96 or something something like
that yeah
but i remember i've just caught up with
the manga with like what the wano arc
which is now one of the longest arcs
it's so long they has three parts
and it still has moments that make
me feel [ __ ] magical this is like
like one piece
is like like i watch some of the best
moments in one piece and i get reminded
this is why i [ __ ] love anime this is
why i like [ __ ] love manga
this is why i love this medium did the
author of one piece like intend for it
to be as long as it is it was just like
[ __ ] it's just popular
i i i think he had planned because the
thing about one piece is that it's this
long and yet
there are there's foreshadowings that
that's happened like
[ __ ] hundreds of chapters not from
this planet that that is that is that is
being explored now
right and i think he didn't expect it to
be this long but he
but when he got popular he realized he
can explore basically every idea he that
he
a lot of people a lot of people i feel
kind of undermine oda just because it's
like oh yeah
you know he made one piece but whatever
it's so long blah blah blah but i think
people when you look deep into it people
really undermine his skill for
storytelling because yeah i mean again
let's be honest you have to be to keep
yeah how many how people like captivated
he's been number one on shonen jump for
the past like 15 years yeah
you don't do that by luck
and like what i find amazing is it's
been going on this long and it's
not one no it's it's not only got still
got [ __ ] amazing moments and
even in some of the greatest uh in some
of the latest chapters and some of the
latest moments
but two no matter how far you go into
one piece
you feel like there's still an upswing
you still you still feel like he hasn't
peaked yet
yeah and like how would you write a
story that's
like almost almost a thousand chapters
long and you still think
man there's an upswing coming there's
there's something greater it's insane
every time a new
arc started yeah and i would keep up to
date with like what the manga
was saying everyone would be like how is
it that the next arc is even better yeah
how does it keep getting better yeah
how does that work i thought this was
the peak and then it just keeps getting
down how does the hot dog stand arc
keep just blowing me away how does the
water park adventure
supreme arc keep blowing me away right
yeah
the names don't make [ __ ] sense it is
literally that pro cd video where he
talks about anime arc names
and like any one piece fan who's watched
that video knows that
he's just calling out one piece fans
there because we were literally talking
about this video before the podcast
started and we were just
me and me and joey was just talking
about the big marmark yeah and then
connie
connor was just like oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah wait that's that's a reality
are you guys serious i thought they were
joking because it was like big mom's
house or something i thought it was just
the joke
like that but i felt that right like
when i when i remember when i've watched
the alabaster arc in one piece
i was like this is the greatest thing
ever made yeah and then water seven came
out i was like how is that how is it
getting better and then the white beard
came out
because frankly i don't really want to
hear your opinions i honestly do not
care
no i already know you okay i already
know your opinions on your name i
already have your hands on fate
bakano is like saying i like coming like
of course
back and i was like i like sex of course
and it's just fun
it's it's it's just fun and then we've
gushed over harihi obviously
right like how disappearance is [ __ ]
amazing horizon as well okay i'm very
i'm
excited to see that yeah because like i
was thinking back to
because like obviously i'm the [ __ ]
isekai man right i was thinking
like lock horizon is the isekai i come
back to because it's it's the only
isekai i've rewatched out of everything
like re-zero i watched because it was my
job you know what i mean like that that
was literally the only reason i watched
zero lock horizon is the only iso i've
come back to be like man
there were some good [ __ ] moments in
this and i really wanted to
re-experience some of these ideas that
well
season three is uh out yeah i'm probably
gonna have re-watching now yeah
yeah it's it's out this season so i'm
probably gonna read like
like verizon's the only like pure isekai
right now that i can
like recommend without it's got no catch
like it's it's not like re-zero where
it's like oh it's
it's a time loop catch you know that's
that's the interesting thing about it
local ryzen it's just hey guys hey guys
yeah there's a gimmick michael ryzen is
just an isakai that is a just a
good iso guy no i agree it deserves to
be it hasn't
placed that idea yeah i just can't get
over the fact that you unironically like
orima
okay i just like for the longest time
what is urimo about i thought it was
like the chinese incest yeah
that's it right it's it's not about
insects it is about
incest just happens in it it's not about
it there's there's there's
there's a key there's a key [ __ ]
difference between the two
it is about incest and best girl getting
cocked that's what that shows about i
can't just say
there's incest in it like it's like like
like a scent of a flavor
you can't just drop that in there be
like oh there's also incest in it like
what
what do you mean is this a small thing
incest to you
it is something okay so so let
i don't care if this like watch this
clips get watch this clip get me
cancelled in like four years or like
[ __ ] four years
watch this clip again for 40 minutes
you know what i mean okay everyone
forgets that orimo
was a legitimately good [ __ ] show
when it first aired i'm gonna have to
stop you right there
it was a i'm gonna have to show you
right there
like like everyone thinks i put orimo on
the same level or something like error
manga sense say no
[ __ ] error manga sensei was trash
from episode one
and it knew it was trash and it it every
manga sensei is what happens
when you take all the trashiest parts of
orimo and put that and put that into a
show
orimo was a nice wholesome look at otaku
culture
and with incest and the thing is
the thing is the thing is when it was
airing everyone was just like oh yeah
this is
this is a parody of all like the incest
light novels and everything like that
right this is this is just this is just
your honor it was but a parody yeah i i
i every one
everyone thought everyone thought that
it was just taking the piss
out of like you know this the little
girl emoto
[ __ ] craze happening in in anime and
level and if if you
if you don't watch the final three
episodes you can watch the entire series
of
series of rmo and just think that um
and then the final three episodes
happened and it
yeah that uh that that sparked an outcry
didn't it it's
it sparked an outcry right it it's it's
uh
it definitely uh because the the reason
the reason it sparked an outcry was
because no one was actually expecting it
yeah it went from like twenty percent
incest to
ninety nine percent it was a hundred
percent it was a hundred there's
there was there was no there was no
percentage that could be shaved off
it went full incest so and it was
unapologetic
fully admit that it went full incentive
no no yeah yeah it's in your top
nine anime because the reason it's okay
i've rewatched it because it is
re-watched it yeah
i've already said i've rewatched
everything on this list i don't i don't
even want to see it
because this this show like
this show is the epitome of everything i
love about trashy harry manga and anime
it's when you say that it just sounds
like satire
sounds like sound it is not okay so
remember when you
went through my anime list and i gave
ikitosin a two yeah so like back when i
was a teenager i was just like you
couldn't appreciate your interest yeah
yeah i'm i'm better than this fan
service [ __ ] i'm i'm better than this
trashy anime
i'm i got a good [ __ ] taste right
this is the show
that [ __ ] changed all that when i was
just like
why am i enjoying this so much why do
why do i like this [ __ ]
filth trash show i mean look look i mean
like
i mean look i look i have shows like
that yeah i kissed cis being a perfect
example yeah i was about to
put it in my [ __ ] three by three
though yeah just probably put an
in this [ __ ] top nine i will middle
oh
i will [ __ ] i that that was a
legitimate deliberate choice i put it in
the middle because i'm just like
this is this show this single show has
probably had the biggest overall effect
on my taste in modern anime you
literally [ __ ] made orima out to be
like the free space in a bingo card you
know what
it's just like yeah of course i'm gonna
open it i [ __ ] did it and
because it is yeah it is it is a [ __ ]
trashy anime right
there there are trashy moments there but
i i think
i will defend the point that orimo
wasn't complete trash there there were
some legitimately good
heartwarming moments in there and it
wasn't complete it wasn't all trash okay
it was it wasn't iron margarita it
really was okay it wasn't harry potter
you're going to jail buddy era manga
sensei is ori emo reskinned
that's all it is and you have to admit
to that no i don't
you have to remember manga sensei is the
trashiest part of orimo
concentrated it is it is dense iron
you're honest
i didn't know she was 12. i'll be honest
your honor ladies and gentlemen this man
has the largest
anime youtube channel on the platform he
also this is what he said i'm
i'm [ __ ] proud of this [ __ ] i put it
i
literally put this stuff front and
center and i regret
that nothing yeah i regret [ __ ]
nothing that is on my computer now and i
can't wait to use it as blackmail all
right let's check out corners
gentlemen here is my nine my my arguably
arguably the strongest nine we've had
today okay you want to go from
top left to bottom so uh hunter hunter
golden time uh boca rano uh ping pong
animation
sakamoto kaiji mob cycle 100 banana fish
and jojo
i'll tell you what this is this is the
guys i have good taste in anime
bro these are good what are you like
like how like genuinely guys guys do you
want to know what personality i have
absolutely no [ __ ] personality this
is that i'm sorry that i i don't like
incest gone is that what you want to see
on my list where's the lack of incest
this is the this is the i cite my
sources in my video essay
like levels of like anime taste you know
what i mean what no
these are legitimately if i had to use a
name like the top
nine shows that i have and like a little
bit of variation genre this would be it
no no
no because i look at this list and i'm
just like yeah i
this is this is what what this is what
my nine by nine would be if i literally
went through my like modern mao
and just pick the top highest rated
anime yeah i'm trying
i'm trying to take my [ __ ] taste in
anime gone and this is my taste
i don't know man i'm sorry that it's too
normal this is no no no
it's not even normie it's just it's try
hard
that's what it feels like legit this
this is legit my my favorite nine shows
okay well i mean obviously we don't have
to talk about hunter hunters
[ __ ] amazing we've talked about
golden time golden time is like my
favorite talked about volcarano
yeah ping pong can you kick him can you
can you talk about ping pong
100 right i love ping pong ping pong
right yeah
other than like mob okay that's also why
i love them all for similar reasons okay
like ping pong is like one of the only
animes right you get all these [ __ ]
stupid animes where the guys opie as
[ __ ]
like it no one [ __ ] gives a [ __ ]
right like okay wow kirito is a giant
dick again right cool
we have another easter kai oh they're
overpowered oh they have an ability
that's unique to them
you know what real life sucks man no one
has a unique ability and i really like
there was a [ __ ] anime that was like
bro
life kind of sucks man sometimes people
just gonna be better at things that you
love
even if they hate it that's what that
was so real and it hurt man
it hurt because i've been on both sides
of the ping pong like animation like
the characters i've been talented at
something that i [ __ ] hated
and i felt bad for people who really
wanted to be good at that thing that i
was good at and i've also tried my
[ __ ] hardest at something and you
speak japanese fluently at birth so
you know i've been on both sides of the
spectrum of pink on the animation so
you know i'm kidding no but i mean
really ping ping pong ping pong
what what i call an what i call ping
pong it's a life animal yeah
it it it hurt because i was like [ __ ]
you really had to like pull that out of
me yeah
that that made me a little like god damn
okay yeah you wait okay then i'm curious
have you seen
uh mosh comes in like a lion no okay
because i
think if you loved ping pong you would
love everyone has told me that yeah
because mars comes in like a lion is the
complete opposite
mars comes in like a lion is about a
genius who
can't understand the idea of losing yeah
right but that in itself is what's
causing him to lose in real life
yeah so it's literally the opposite of
ping pong but that's just like that's
just like the school when they're like
you're a gifted child and they
can't [ __ ] do anything later on right
exactly i mean and obviously like uh i
don't want to know
why why is sakamoto there okay why why
is that what is wow
why why is that a top night man that's
so [ __ ] funny man
i'll have to stand with my
sakamoto is one of the funniest animals
sakamoto is so good
it's so funny it's so funny you can put
that [ __ ] on it's like the mr bean of
anime
it's like the mr bean of anime if mr
bean was like a [ __ ]
like handsome millionaire who was
perfected anyway
[ __ ] so you really gotta diss me when
you just like were like yeah pedophilia
brotherly in love okay here's what i
don't understand though what
every three by three right as we've
established so far and every three by
three i've seen back when it was big
has at least one show that's [ __ ]
like universally right yeah [ __ ]
i think all these shows are [ __ ]
fantastic one which is why
it's simple which is why i suppress
extra doubt i just don't like [ __ ] shows
jerry
what do you think i'm gonna put like my
ho my ho demon or some [ __ ] in this no
that thing was made as [ __ ]
i don't know like you don't have like a
do you have a guilty pleasure anime
honestly no not really
really i don't really watch anime ever
[Music]
wow the grand reveal i i frankly
again i've revealed this before i never
i never [ __ ] want to re-watch anime
right so yeah
so you wouldn't re-watch any of these no
okay why would i be watching i've
already watched
because it's great because dude you
don't want to re-experience it not
really
i'll be honest with you i'd rather
experience something different so
there's no show like you would never
like have you never gotten to the point
right where you're just you just
you're just tired of trying something
new and because
no no you're you're tired of trying
something new why do you make it sound
so sad
i'm just tired of trying yeah i'm going
to go back towards this because because
sometimes you try something new and
you're just like man this just ain't
doing it for me you just want something
you want something that's
it's comfort food yeah it's you know
yeah i don't know for me that feels sad
it feels like you're trying to capture
something that's gone in your life you
know what i mean i don't know i feel sad
too i am in this photo and i don't like
it
like i don't know like you're chasing
something that doesn't exist anymore in
my mind
why is melanie laughing at me because in
my mind right i'm gonna i could
i could easily i would watch like any of
these yes
would i willingly do it at my own free
world no no because like i
to to bring it the other way like for me
watching new shows
is me chasing that high that that is me
chasing
that high that i felt with the shows
i've already liked but
the more anime you watch and just the
older you [ __ ] get that just gets
harder and harder
i don't watch my channel anymore and
that's
that's the biggest like reveal of this
video god
doesn't watch anything no i do i watch
anime
i mean look honestly like i i i'm
feeling sauce about this three by three
just because again
because all nine of these shows are like
universally praised all right right it's
golden time universally praised yeah
i i i like ordinary
like in my mind it's like my two
favorite like romance or whatever
like yeah yeah yeah toradora and golden
time but golden time felt like the
better because
golden time is my favorite romance of
all time i would think
and yeah i thought that you guys didn't
like golden time
i love going on time okay okay i've met
less people who say they didn't like
golden time yeah really
yeah because like the thing about golden
time is that you know
there are there were flaws because no
who the [ __ ] liked bannery as a
character
let's be honest like i just okay like
you talk talking about compressing your
memory like i i've only just remembered
that ghost binary was a thing
and that was just something i've just
like that was like a black spot yeah in
this like
amazing series that i seem to remember
golden time but like i think that's a
golden time i just think
this is this is how adult romance should
be this is this took
everything that was good as you said
about toradora and just made it better
yeah perfected it put it in university
didn't make it like just this high
school romance had enough adult elements
that
didn't have an annoying ass [ __ ]
lolli
it's sad that no one gives a chance but
also weird that it's only in 720p
that's pretty [ __ ] weird no 480p i
think or something really yeah
it was never released oh yeah yeah it is
in 480p it's in 480p
and it's such a shame because like it's
it's such a [ __ ] good show
but it was either that or like one ounce
i really [ __ ] like one hour
but i mean i i don't know like there's i
mean
i guess it it looks very basic from the
outside looking no
it's not basic it's not basically
because it's it's not basic in the sense
where you thought we were putting on
nine favorite shows like oh like
no we were but what we're saying is that
like there isn't a single guilty
pleasure anime here
because obviously guilty pleasure anime
is bad or an emo that's more than a
guilty pleasure that's a criminal
pleasure joey i think
in my opinion the guilty pleasure is a
show that you love no matter what even
though
you know it is [ __ ] yeah okay but then i
when i was making this nine by nine
let's say dead man wonderland i love
dead man wonderland but it never
finished and it was you know it was kind
of you know it was kind of made because
of it
but like i don't think it's better than
any of these shows for me perhaps
because like i've i've talked to you and
i know what your tastes are basically
and i
yeah yeah like i i know you love like
[ __ ] hardcore brutal shows
like jojo bakki gantz i love
um i'm surprised that i thought becky
was gonna i thought bucky was gonna be
up there as well
well i mean i love baki as like there's
because there's a few episodes in
backyard like yeah it's like mid but
there was just so many [ __ ] funny
moments that like it all stand with me
forever
here's the best way i can do this i know
you like chad shows
that's that's the best way to get like a
chat that's the best way i can describe
honest taste like like it's it's like
just it's just got chad characters isn't
it you know what i mean chad characters
yeah that's that
that's why i really want connor to watch
or read fists than all stuff yeah yeah
i know you would [ __ ] love that yeah
i like the right amount of chat
if there's just too much chat sometimes
a little too much you know it's like
sometimes
what do you mean you like jojo that's
like 100
that's a different that's a different
that's a different kind of chat that's
like that jojo is like the built
different anime like that's in its own
league
as far as i can say like i think jody
shouldn't even be treated as anime it's
a lifestyle
yeah it's an artwork but like i don't
know like in first of the north star
when i see that i don't really find it
appealing because they're like they're
just like
too macho i want a bit of weakness to
the character right i mean if you read
it you'll know
every character is weak as [ __ ] really
okay okay fine fine
i think you should read it you'll love
it yeah but yeah it pisses me off when
i'm watching an anime
and the main character is like a wimp
beyond com comprehension and just causes
any problems for himself because he's a
wimp and i'm like yeah listen
all you have to do is just say no and
you wouldn't have been dragged off to a
culture are you talking about deku
i don't know something else there's a
lot of shows where i'm just like this
literally could have been avoided if you
just like stood up to yourself for about
two seconds like this whole problem
you know i don't know man i'm not
satisfied
what do you want from me huh just some
[ __ ] you know what i mean like you're
expecting me to have [ __ ]
this is like this is like this is like
too polished i i i i i have good taste
what can i say i can i can make a better
nine uh three by three
make my three by three for me okay it
would be like i was like i said i'll see
if it's fat it would be
jojo yeah but like
i love baki but it's not in my top nine
shows
but you talk about it so often yeah but
it like i love it but it's i wouldn't
put it
higher than any of these for enjoyment
in my mind but like
it's it's okay because shows that i love
and show that i want to talk about
are like different i guess but it's okay
like this
this is like getting this we should have
defined the rules more appropriately
right should be like connor give me the
nine shows that you think about keep you
up at night
yeah yeah yeah because that's what i did
i i did why didn't sorry they used to
put your nine favorite shows that
represent you well like
what i don't understand is you say that
like the shows i talk about and the
shows i like are not the same yeah why
would you talk about a show if it's not
your favorite
there's some shows where it's like well
ping pong right right it's all of it is
encapsulated in the show there's nothing
more to adam like just [ __ ] watch it
but like
it's like amazing love it i can't i
can't improve it nobody's
talking about it that that's that's the
exact point right because you sometimes
you see a good show and you're like
[ __ ] me that was a good show like like i
need to talk about it yeah yeah but
sometimes you watch a show and you're
like man this is this is sticking with
me you know what i mean this is
i i i'm stuck with me huh yeah no i'm
not saying ping pong shouldn't be on
this but like
what shouldn't be on this hunter hunter
bro fight
dude honda hunter prove that [ __ ] that
[ __ ] moved me
man i don't know
i hear you talking more about bucky than
hunter yeah that's because
okay let's be like that's right psycho
and hunter i
rarely hear you talking about that i
never talking about these okay
i talk about one punch man more than i
talk about mob psycho right in one punch
because i think mob psych is a better
show than one punch man well then why
wouldn't you talk about mob psycho if
it's a better show
well again because it's a bad show and i
feel like there's not much to say it's
[ __ ] amazing like just go watch it
like
but it's like like my favorite show i
love becky right where i have to sit
there and be like listen get to the part
where he [ __ ] someone and becomes
extra powerful like i love having that
conversation again if you haven't seen
becky there is a scene where he has
only one scene yeah honestly and that
one scene
is enough to be like anime of the year
in my mind just like
give it another that's that's exactly
what i'm [ __ ] talking about
that's a scene that's stuck with you and
you can bring up and you want to bring
up
so why would that not be in your number
three it's like the way
that i see it is that like let's say god
wants to take me to like an event and
he's like he has to specifically tell me
like connor don't bring up the backy sex
scene to like my friends
that's the level of like i just want to
talk about it like that it's not like it
defines my taste for some reason i just
want to talk about that scene and how
[ __ ] weird because because like i
like kind of kind of talking to you i
know what
what kind of shows you would like you
know you you look at someone's three
over three and you can like recommend
some shows that they would like for
example
like i knew for example that you would
love a show like dota head
you know what i mean because that that
that that is crazy it's grimy it's a
chad anime
you know what i mean it's just corner it
just you know it's it's like
if i i'm just gonna say if i didn't see
this three by three
and you told me like no no and if you
ask me recommend me an anime
ping pong is the last one i would bring
up for me for you why
it again it just doesn't seem like a
show you would like what i love that
that's actually like top three
foundation
the biggest the biggest one for me is
like
mob psycho and hunter hunter hunter is
my favorite show
[ __ ] sorry hunt hunter is my favorite
showing of all time what about jojo
i don't really count that as a shonen it
is a show
but it is a show because it has to be
categorized but there's no there's no
jojo category but there should be as far
as i'm concerned
you know okay that's what is the jojo
category then i cause
jojo is like it's own beast right like i
can't i there's nothing you can compare
jojo to no i i i agree with him a lot i
i disagree i i compare jordan to
something right now do it bucky
[ __ ] off no no no no it's not it's not
exactly the same
it's not exactly i'm not saying they're
both the same thing right but they give
off the same kind of
feeling you know what i mean where it's
just like there are some ridiculous
[ __ ] things happening and you're just
happy
good times yes but i'm not i'm not
saying that they're on like the same
level or anything
but they give off the same vibe is what
i'm talking about but
i've always said that they're just both
[ __ ] insane but the thing is i reduce
that
a bunch of 80s and 90s shown in back
then
had this kind of feel to it yeah like
fist the nostar
also has scenes where it's just like
what the [ __ ] did i just read
and you just recommended them that to
him because he said no that's yeah
that's what that's exactly what i'm
saying
jojo were like halfway through was like
right let's just be gay now like that
that's
that's like i love that no trust me
there's a lot of gay parts in fizzling
is that really oh yeah i just thought it
was like the manliest manly anime
in existence like no i guess that's
pretty gay and that is pretty good
that's pretty good that's pretty gay
there's a thing called i don't know if
you're aware of that i'm just gonna say
the ymca
[Music]
banana fish is one of my favorite shows
as well i [ __ ] love them yeah yeah
but fish is great
blonde fish isn't good but but i'm but i
was expecting that because you've talked
about it
right you've even made a whole video on
bananafish so i expected that
but so you're complaining that i picked
good shows is that
yes because everybody's three by three
has to have at least
one show where it's like hold on
honestly let's see if i can put a bad
show that i like
in my three by three there's got to be
at least one guilty pleasure see
the money there's gonna be what i'm
saying is
every three by three has to have at
least one shitty show that you know is
shitty
look look honestly what is it uh the
world got in the nose that's a [ __ ]
shirt would you put that on yet
honestly yeah probably would but you see
when i'm making this right we had like
what like an hour to make this i'm
thinking like boom i'm putting my
favorites on there they're classic stuff
yeah
okay okay okay here's here's a better
working word i understood more about you
as a person
from your hentai tastes than i did from
this yeah but that's
okay i mean that's very okay i feel like
anyone could hear my hentai taste and
figure out
hmm connor recommends mother knows
breasts i wonder what he's into
yeah that is true i i look at this and
i'm like this could be
anyone's three this this was a this was
a
randomly generated image made by this is
like
it's like this this was made by an ai
learning program
from like the a randomly generated
sample from
people's top like i i i put in the ai
but this is an offensive three by three
yeah this is what came out there's a lot
of them in like in good faith i couldn't
put on there because i'm like i honestly
don't [ __ ] remember much from the
show
so like i don't know what to put on
there like so this is a these are like
the nine shows right if you like name
name nine shows that you love right away
these are the first nine that come
together okay i'll be honest with you
honestly i i me maybe it does make sense
because rem do you think rem is your
[ __ ] wife yeah
what i'm trying to say is i like good
shows too connor i'm sorry that you like
haruhi suzumiya evangelion and uh black
lagoon the most two thousands like of
anime in existence and the fact is
that that's good the fact is the fact is
that you got something about what my
[ __ ] taste is which is you can get it
about this i like good [ __ ] why is that
hard to understand again
i look at this this could be any one of
our fans well
this could be this could be our fans
have good taste this could be any one of
our fans who was like trying to impress
us being like yes
my favorite youtuber i also have good
anime taste
i have good taste what are you going to
do about it have [ __ ] taste jokes that
you want yeah i was expecting listen i'm
built differently if i wanted
anyone to have a [ __ ] taste it was you
no no no uh should we check out
maylene's
okay so we we have uh we have another
one to check out melinda we can speed
running
come on come on the podcast man come on
come on come on come on you've got to
defend this [ __ ] come on melon come on
all right as a bonus guess we have
maylene our manager
we are the person who is managing us and
i i i'm a woman who might do a person
who works
for one of the biggest japanese
publishing companies i'm i'm i'm i'm
proud of you melin
because this is the literal opposite of
conor right here
like you you were not [ __ ] scared to
go balls deep
and show us who you really are listen i
gave you what i really am gone
so let's go let's go basically thank you
man [ __ ] said it your [ __ ] basic
vanilla is a flavor that needs to exist
and i have that all right let's go over
it though
so from top left to bottom right we have
monster from the new world utano prince
summer
jojo vampire knight golden kamui story
of saiyun koko
sures and hakuoki what the [ __ ] is the
story of seinkoku what is
that do you want to explain yourself
melin yeah especially i can't
explain myself this is literally i like
the true crime
the taste isn't it it is yeah it is
you got jojo's monster and then you've
got all the like
i've watched all of these at least
two or two to five times each yeah you
you went by the same thing
yeah yeah you would like i did not
influence her she saw the same thing
where
it's the shows you re-watch and the
shows you just go back to yeah because
i've heard maylene talking about monster
utano prince summer
jojo golden kamui yeah she's the guy
yodi it's the bottom three that i'm
curious about
most of my body pillows are the hakwoki
the bottom
okay yeah let me preface that i think
out of
out of all of us melin owns more body
pillows than the three of us put
together
how many you are how many do you want
right now in japan
well together including in the us how
many do you oh like
50. but hold on hold on they're they're
not all big body pillows
that doesn't make you any better we're
not asking about the size
we're asking about the number and i do
have that
five zero five zero because i do have
like i'm gonna finish it out boys
i knew queen of degenerate degeneracy
has come along i even have
you know the body spray to make the
pillow smell like the official character
oh my god
because why not you want to know what
they smell like
do you boys honestly want me to be like
this this is what you wanted from me
yeah
honestly listen you can be the weird one
this guy likes his children he can have
that i'm gonna be normal thank you very
much i
i think i take enough l's in the other
[ __ ]
i add i got a thorough grilling on the
hentai episode for having normal taste
i'm i'm
happy to have normal taste this time
okay i've heard of
i've watched ceres actually that one's
incestuous
[Laughter]
there's two incestuous anime on here the
vampire knight
full of yeah people what is this
a vampire night yeah vampire not even
yeah this is [ __ ] super nice
again i mentioned i i do not know
anything about the show the only thing i
know is the only person who loved that
show turned out to be a better one
i'm not a pedophile i don't know man i
don't know
but uh yeah i mean i can't explain i
can't explain
images don't even have high-res images
like they're so [ __ ] old dude
i will though say that this one's in
like minecraft potato quality
that one's really trashy like it's like
120p it's really bad
isn't that just a shitty gadget game no
no no no no
that's you just know that because
melinda
yeah so like i it's like out of everyone
here mainly
yours is the only one that has shows
that i've never heard of
um what is what is this show
so you know the secret police basically
in japan
yeah yeah like you know version secret
police did you just say the shonen
version
like pretty boy
yeah yeah i mean we can see that we
all of this right like from the new
world it's the one that stands out the
most
did you just did you just put this did
you just put this in to be like this is
guys
guys guys i got a little bit of a taste
in there
is literally mainly saying yes i am a
functioning human in society
i'm normal i like normal shows monster
is pretty normal
yeah monster golden color is very golden
chemical normal
i am a normal human being no number five
though but these two i know
i know why i know why you're like
monster and golden camellia because you
you like like you said you like your
crew time
murder [ __ ] man also you could do a
[ __ ] yeah johan's so sexy
thank you thank you very much for
joining us wow
that was some trash taste you could say
i'm glad to know that the producer for
trash taste has trash taste
but you know what it was more
entertaining than connor's [ __ ]
vanilla
yeah that was the better way to do it i
can't always be the [ __ ] weirdo like
i have that most of the time come on
leave me alone what do you mean the
weirdo i've always the one being like
right
i'm gonna say something you guys are
like what the [ __ ] i'm sick and tired of
it
well hopefully you guys enjoyed this
episode
[ __ ] hey you know who doesn't have trash
taste
there's a reason why you enjoy this show
it's because you have trash taste but
hey if you'd like to join us on patreon
then make sure to go to patreon.comtaste
also follow us on twitter uh the
subreddit and also
join us on spotify if you don't want to
see our faces um
wow you know what how when was the last
time we actually did a show or an
episode that was
fully funny about anime about adam
riddens if you ask me honestly like i
hope you enjoyed your only
anime trash chase episode for like the
next six months
we'll see you in around uh august i feel
like there's not that much you can
say though like you can have a two-hour
discussion about the anime you like but
like you can't do it every week
yeah that is true that is true but uh
hopefully you guys enjoyed
this is why you're not a nanny book yeah
yeah this is what yeah that's why you
don't watch
like i can agree with that given the
[ __ ] list you just gave us
because what the [ __ ] do you have to say
about it absolutely [ __ ] nothing
that's more connor i thought i would
just take w's man what do you want from
me i'm just i'm i just put good
i think in today's episode you took an l
i did not come on
this is this look look look if if if
everyone did a
list like you would be the most boring
[ __ ] episode
like somebody has all the time normal
that's me today okay go on don't hate me
for that
let us know what you think down in the
comments below we're looking forward to
what you guys say
but uh yeah hopefully you guys enjoyed
this episode and uh i've been joey
and with the boys and uh we'll see you
guys soon we'll see you guys next time
bye
[Music]
you